[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
yo yo yo yo salut à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau live salut le Vlad ça le
Kiev salut le francophone
fleur et donc le retour de 4 pour pour
Yann les pomyachive là que tu avais
prévu bien évidemment qu'est-ce que je
peux E4 non
ah oui oui oui
bien sûr
alors quel petite ligne il va nous
sortir cette fois-ci
je suis à un petit peu intrigué il est
vrai que il est connu que
un épaules n'est pas très connu pour
être très performant après les défaites
moi on va voir qu'est-ce que ça va ça va
donner aujourd'hui alors il a eu un jour
de repos quand même ouais il a quand
même eu ce que joue un drôle très
important bien sûr donc le moment
le plus intéressant pour moi va
t'arriver je pense au sixième coup
quand on va avoir
les positions classiques de l'espagnol
sur l'échiquier et puis donc il va opter
pour se soucis encore une fois il va
opter pour
1 ou pour deux trois donc là le moment
arrive
peut-être parce qu'il peut y avoir des
petites nuls
non non
je suppose ok il y a beaucoup normal il
a décidé
et puis le plus probablement à 3 mais
pas que après 25 faut pas trop à B6 très
possible qu'il va opter pour pour foudre
de 2 ce qui devient très très à la mode
et je me vois de dire que cette idée
avec vous de deux qui paraît être
bizarrement fait très intéressantes a
été mise en mode en audio
qui a été introduit pour nous d'ailleurs
l'idée c'est marrante d'ailleurs
l'idée c'est que
après petit rock je joue H3 qui vient
je joue H3 et si le noir joue kobolais à
5 faut se dos c'est 5 j'ai rien contre
de jouer les même avec un père de tempo
je joue de 4
et ça va et ça va ouais parce que en
fait c'est très questionnaire ou le tour
est mis au procès sur par exemple après
elle est dans les structures damso c'est
de 5 souvent dans les milieux pour la
société
[Musique]
F4
bien sûr son adversaire est au courant
de cette ligne cette ligne est devenue
assez connu parmi les
idées les plus intéressantes récentes je
peux citer celle-là jouer au parcmir
donc c'est si vous voulez le comme ça
très intéressant ah je l'ai vu ça normal
ouais c'est intéressant ça je pense que
l'idée vraiment firs
petite question voilà est-ce que tu te
rappelles de la cartouche qui avait mis
mvl dans l'espagnol aux candidats contre
Ding
vaguement
vaguement mais tu te rappelles que une
belle cartouche je pense qu'il y avait
une ligne longue avec deux trois non
il est vraiment bien et le foufou avait
fait une erreur juste à la sortie de
l'ouverture et c'était tout de suite
fini oh là
non mais j'ai juste ça parce que est-ce
que le foufou va réussir à tenir ici
en fait
les petites lignes il est assez elle est
assez Triki en fait parce que les Noirs
ont pointe option le point d'option un
peu par exemple l'essayer de jouer dans
le style de SNCF football
carpovestre j'aurais dit même que tu
vasque tu aurais fait aussi ah oui quand
à l'espagnol quand il y a une ligne
bizarre qui vous arrive dans la gueule
vous savez pas quoi faire à 6,8 dans les
mois dire des cas c'est une très très
bonne réaction ouais genre tu il a fait
fou B7 ah ouais
prévisible donc pas trop malin parce que
prévisible parce que avant de venir
devenir joueur de marché pendant
le joueur
c'est un rapport avec les lapins bien
sûr parce que Zayat sandrus c'est
d'ailleurs
très joli sourire quoi sur la route ici
j'ai appris que nouvelle série télévisée
dont tout le monde parle c'est rabbestro
c'est sur quels
avec ton acteur préféré celui de 24
heures kiffes
nouvelle position nouveau challenge tu
connais non pas du tout moi je peux dire
tout de suite c'est quoi l'idée parce
que
si les Noirs jouent dans le style de
breir ce qui arrive souvent une fois
quand vous jouez haitif vous
vous transférez souvent
l'idée
peut-être pas tout de suite peut-être
tout de suite je pense C4
très très
MVLS
si Bruxelles
parce que le Fou est sur les grandes
diaganes à l'époque sur ce weed si
brigade au lieu de bosser
de nouveau que c'est 5 que 3 et vous
visez
très très
dans la dernière position je peux
montrer à notre truc stratégique
de ce 5 que le 3 imaginons joue ici par
exemple comment les dessins et l'une des
idées quand elle bouffe au lieu de 5 par
exemple CD après que le collège
et ça peut être long et pénible
dégueulasse
toujours
je me suis dit mais comment c'est
possible que je suis né de cette manière
alors
ça peut être quoi ce réflexe
bah juste comme ça sans réfléchir
cavalier de 7 par exemple avec les deux
cavaliers C5 pour avoir de la dame
souvent le plus souvent le plus souvent
d'abord pour activer la dame et puis
pour tu vas rigoler mais ah non tu vas
pas rigoler pour homme
tu sais tu vas rigoler j'ai joué une
fois l'espagnol au noir
parce que j'entends mais pas les 5 tu
vois rigoler je joue une espagnole avec
les doigt c'est déjà rigolo
4 5 pour jouer l'espagnol avec les Noirs
une seule fois j'ai fait et c'est assez
drôle enfin une seule fois contre un
joueur fort mais j'ai dû faire contre
des joueurs plus faibles parce que après
la partie j'ai pas compris pourquoi j'ai
perdu et je monte la partie à muretas et
je crois qu'il y a rien qui allait en
fait j'ai fait tout un plan pour
ma de Daman à 8 je sais pas
comment j'ai foutu pour faire des cinq
et le mec a juste ramené toutes ces
pièces et ma maté c'est juste pas
compris quoi mais je peux te faire jouer
l'espagnol chaque deuxième partie tu
veux
[Musique]
[Rires]
des trucs comme ça j'ai entamé ça
ça
pour faire ça
l'idée sur dame 2 pour faire dame B5
ok
une autre idée
une autorité taillée pour toi
vas-y Caro Caro
D4
avec les décoller 3 je trouve etc
ok c'est fini tout de suite en fait
alors il a fait quoi
il joue donc plus ou moins dans les
manières classiques mais il connaît en
critique
mon expérience analytique
faut que je sens que mais jamais trop
dangereux parce que c'est pas une menace
et parce que en tas de réactions comme
si je joue Bullet et je vais pas
réfléchir je joue tempo
et je vais au moins terrement
un beau jour je vais mettre mon droit
sur H8 français
mais je comprends jamais cette position
est-ce que tu veux dire que c'est une
prepa liquide non moi je pense qu'il y a
peut-être une petite ce qu'on a un petit
est-ce que on appelle les Russes check
out quoi
oui j'ai pas une petite idée là quelque
part est-ce que tu peux sûrement pas un
grand chose mais quelque chose est-ce
que tu peux frimer avec un cavalier de 5
merci pour me donner l'occasion de
briller techniquement
[Rires]
c'est quoi le palmarès de Vlad champion
d'Europe individuel et c'est tout en
fait je gagnais un seul tournoi dans mon
lit je peux non de repos
plus beau titre championnat de champion
d'Europe individuel c'est ton plus beau
de France 2 troisième fois execo m'a
perdu au départ
de l'histoire des échecs aussi
enfermés
le championnat de Moscou
et c'était pas un blister
fort à baloutchouc à Moscou si je
gagnais moyen au padonnante mais il y
avait tous les meilleurs sinon
enfin je gagnais deux trois trucs mais
ok
les champions d'Europe individuel c'est
quand même ton plus beau titre on est
d'accord
c'est celui qui est sur ma carte de
visite
celui qu'un certain Étienne Bacro n'a
pas réussi à obtenir
[Rires]
alors ouais donc parlant de la pause
très très dur de ne pas jouer au huit la
mort a insiste absolument de faire ce
coup donc ce veut dire qu'il doit y
avoir une petite idée quelque part pour
les bois moi je le vois pas
qui quand même non
ok il est vrai j'ai commencé de jouer à
contourner comme elle était très très
jeune
en ta faveur
quand même
il doit pas être bien
je dois dire que j'ai moins de qui est
encore
[Rires]
mais par contre t'as pas un gros score
contre Fab
avec les bons
fait passer ça pour une énorme
performance de sa part
je n'ai perdu qu'une fois contre vlades
[Musique]
et le score de Murtas contre Baki
ok
déjà je pense que ils se sont joués
beaucoup moins que nous avec bac je
pense parce que moi avec Bouaké quand
même
mais tu sais que mardi normalement tu
commentes avec Baki
bon nickel c'est beau nickel et lundi
soir si tu veux venir on suivra Baki qui
joue un tournoi rapide
dans le rêve non il sera chez toi mais
si tu veux on peut le suivre ici enfin
moi je suivrai ce que je suis toujours
baquet en fait enfin là tu sais il joue
en Bundesliga autrichienne bon tout le
monde connaît Baki ici évidemment et il
a deux sur deux pour le moment
d'ailleurs comment s'appelle Bundesliga
je pense que ça s'appelle start League
je pense
ce que je pense je pense que
Bundesliga ou un truc comme ça mais déjà
nous on dit pas s on dit bundesh en fait
nous on transforme les S en jeu
généralement mais c'est vraiment
important
quelle que soit la langue
j'ai vu que tu avais gagné la première
et j'ai check la deuxième du presse
mais j'ai pas de chèque ce matin au
story
c'est important pour Maxime en ce moment
le classement et love latte parce que
pour la Coupe du Monde c'est pas sûr
qu'il est sa place ils ont changé les
règles et la Fédération peut plus donner
la welcard ne peut donner la walkard
qu'un joueur qui a joué les Olympiades
c'est ouf d'avoir fait ça
en tant que punition
c'est pas Maxime il dit que ça a donné
plus en donne encore plus de pouvoir et
de poids aux fédérations nationales ce
qui est pas forcément top
vu les conflits qui peuvent exister dans
certaines fédérations c'est un peu
étonnant un vrai dire j'ai jamais vu
trop de pouvoir donner aux figurations
en fait parce que d'après ce que je vis
par exemple aller en Russie les
meilleurs joueurs peuvent faire tout ce
qu'ils veulent les fidèles accepte
d'après ce que je veux
en Russie
un chien peut être assez différent mais
je peux pas dire que je suis pas un
grand fana de figuration moi je peux pas
dire que les autres pouvoirs
mais ça peut donc pour certains pays pas
pour tous mais pour certains ça peut
être ok peut-être quelque part peut-être
un chien je sais pas moi en Russie non
aux États-Unis non en Arménie non
il y a beaucoup de pays dans le monde il
est vrai
bon G5 il réfléchit mais il a forcément
dans son fichier non encore il avait
l'air tellement de connaitre
OK
je vous ai dit déjà que je pense que
c'est juste un bon coup mais quoi faire
sinon parce que avec le fou sur ADO
normalement tu veux pas faire tout Oui
et entamer un tel coup comme un chien
on est d'accord
non dans les grands plus part de cas en
fait 4 ans 10% des cas le faux Brand est
mal placé sur toi dans l'espagnol et
c'est pas la case où il appartient
d'ailleurs non non mille fois le plus
souvent les myopercession que sur trois
parce qu'il boucle le jour blanc en fait
sur l'autre donc faut acheter débile
parce que parce que
[Musique]
maintenant il faut comprendre qu'est-ce
que je cherche par exemple le jour que
vous voulez à 3 il veut jouer sur casse
blanche du coup normalement il doit
viser ça donc
ok moi je non un jour un coup lambda B4
les branches jouent que voler ces quatre
les Noirs prennent pour ce cadre quelque
chose comme ça et on se demande et
qu'est-ce que c'est après tout parce que
d'habitude c'est rien en fait depuis cet
objectif
parce que quand tu vas préparer pour 200
et les prix est prise avec le four avec
une pièce pardon je veux jouer du foot
mais peut-être oui ici tu peux pas jouer
au foot de 5 ou 200
tu peux pas te permettre ça donc et
sinon les Noirs violent le tour brute et
je veux dire après je vais remettre la
variante
non non non tu bouges pas tout de suite
et tu prépares à leur tour
parce que les Noirs veulent justice fou
je sais trois bougies
et en fait les bras contrôles comme quoi
les gaz
d'ailleurs
l'une des idées de
du choix de Virtu de ne pas aujourd'hui
ça peut être je me rappelle il y avait
un match très très long carcène Ding à
Saint-Louis
et presque dans chaque partie Carson a
joué l'une des versions de antibiant une
deuxième troisième quatrième 5e 6e à
chaque fois elle a changé et ok le match
se terminait pour un massacre
donc vous voyez ce que je veux dire que
le joueur
ils se sont dit que le mec a très bien
préparé théoriquement mais peut-être
dans les petits détails stratégiques
parce qu'il y a une myriade de
souverainte peut-être il est comme quoi
pas tout à fait confirme est-ce que tu
as pas l'impression que les roscov
déconne en fait
les Rosco déco souvent mais pas trop
souvent à ce stade de l'ouverture et pas
dans le troisième partie c'est un peu
trop
tôt non je pense pas qu'il déconne moi
peut-être ils veulent quelque chose
il viole il viole un petit chèque
[Musique]
parce que l'autre savait pas jouer les
deux premières parties et ils viennent
de se faire défoncer dans les deux
dernières rondes
non
souvent de quoi comme exemple le compte
Carson tout le monde a été déconnant une
grosse déconnage quotidienne
ou c'est une époque qui déconne
bah tous ensemble
tous ensemble tous réunis
dans la décodade
[Rires]
collectif
commence à se faire défoncer comme la
dernière fois contre Carlson qui
reperdre de la même manière
et que dans deux ans il ré-entame un
nouveau match contre un mec vraiment pas
trop fort mais que ce soit quand même
pareil quoi
juste n'importe quoi
en tout cas il marche beaucoup autour de
l'échiquier aujourd'hui
où est-ce que nouveau d'ailleurs parce
que
[Musique]
avant on en a parlé que du bide oui je
pense qu'un jourd'hui on peut parler
moins de
des tétons
[Rires]
bravo mec parlant
[Musique]
en fait moi j'essaie de le guetter pour
voir quand il revient
écoute je pense qu'il doit dresser
habitué au magasin de l'Algérie quoi
comme disent les Américains
en plus moi c'est un sujet avec avec ma
petite fille en bas âge que je connais
bien en ce moment
les sujets n'étaient pas être un jeu
je crois que si jamais il y a un
problème j'appelle des pots
je sais que spécialiser
H6 ok le coup le deuxième coup le plus
logique ou le premier coup le plus
logique
ok il revient mais c'est vrai il est
quand même présent en haut en bas et au
milieu quoi
[Rires]
il est présent à tous les niveaux ok
donc c'est ça son idée c'est fou frère
un peu robotique ok au lieu de Cavalia
grosse surprise c'est toujours pas
possible moi d'habitude un jour
c'est tellement moyen d'après sa gueule
non les Russes décote
ils ont comme
dans le stéréotype qu'on imagine dans
l'archétype et le stéréotype qu'on
imagine des Russes on imagine des gens
très solide mentalement
bon parce que peut-être la rigueur
soviétique
parce que moi même les rayures se vit-il
au fond de les rigueur climatiques ce
qui fait froid oui donc si tu veux tu
dois faire savoir faire face aux
circonstances pas très favorables tu
dois être dur quoi tu dois interdire et
quand tu veux te dire donc tu échanges
ton fou tu échanges ton pion tu mets ton
corps
[Musique]
si l'idée c'est tout un que voit les
femmes etc bah ça va prendre un deux
trois enfants pas mal de tempo et de
toute manière
et alors quelle tête qui veut tout rond
cavalier F1 qui a validé 3 pour la case
D5 mais ouais c'est pas grand chose en
tout cas ok moi je suis un mec simple
d'ailleurs je suppose sur 200 qu'il veut
quoi parce que sur
l'aérien je suppose donc non il vit
quand même
un petit peu mieux
non
moi joueur de scandinave avec les Noirs
je prends tous les jours
[Rires]
ça j'en joue tous les matins non mais
c'est rien ça d'accord dans ce cas-là
peut-être elle vu au robot avec le pion
non non avec le pion non c'est pas mieux
non non non non c'est encore
je dis le petit ordi
c'est jusqu'à temps bah écoute donc ils
nous ont passé une grosse question
aujourd'hui alors
ok bien sûr quand votre adversaire à
Blitz out tout ce coup aussi vite ça
donne pas trop d'envie de vérifier et
qui est-ce que les préparés sur des 5
parce que je suppose il est à préparer
quand même quelque chose sur de 5 si
c'est pas de 5 bon maman veut faire un
autre coup c'est dans ce set
c'est pas parce que je veux
jouer ces quatre tout de suite mais
parce que
je veux lier le tour et un jour quand
les bois quand ici les doigts vont jouer
tours j'ouvre pour ce C4 donc dans ce
set c'est un autre cours que normalement
doit être fait ou bien si on veut pas du
tout réfléchir à ne finir pas possible
ou bien
mais ce qu'on va pas en fait où c'est
dangereux mais après moi je joue
tellement mal les Espagnols dis-toi que
dans les Espagnols je suis cataclysmique
mais tu sais comment ça se fait souvent
de telles prépa
c'est rien c'est l'ordinateur donne un
petit quelque chose quelque chose oui et
l'heure du matin et archi four j'en ai
par exemple sans réseau neurologique et
tu joues contre les lignes contre leur
dit après J6 toujours contre leur dit
après que les saucisse toujours contre
le Diable etc à chaque fois leur dit
arrive de te battre et là tu te dis
tiens c'était partout rien
pourquoi pas essayer tu vois parce que
la façon de traiter ça par l'ordinateur
parfois peut être très bizarre
complètement en demeure mais ouais mais
il a pas réussi à le faire du coup c'est
un peu ce dont parlait guéri il y a pas
si longtemps il a donné une interview il
disait vous savez il y a des prépas où
l'ordi donne plus 0,3 + 0,4 mais en fait
il y a aucun coût qui est qui fait je
comprends ce que tu dis quoi après tu es
déjà moins bien
oui oui
donc là c'est à vrai dire quelle que
soit la position que tu mets dans la
main ton ordinateur il te bat quand même
déjà les questions de maintenant
est-ce que les bons menacent de jouer
photos
on va jouer un coup un peu comme ça
juste pour faire pas grand chose
je suppose que c'est une menace
ça a pas l'air d'aller ça donne trop de
cases
non le plus grand problème c'est oui
c'est pour ça que vaut mieux donner pas
à jouer
il doit vouloir quelque chose parce que
d'habitude si après des cinq terriens
c'est juste que tu arrêtes l'analyse
mais est-ce que ça peut pas être un blog
du coup
l'emporte que ça car c'est quand même
[Musique]
comme ça genre parce que lui il se dit
si c'est dessin que le seul coup qui
égalise vraiment admettons mais tu as
joué vite jusque là et donc regarde
l'autre se dit sur des seins qu'il a
forcément quelque chose donc il le fait
pas
je comprends
pas du tout ça marche parfois mais au
moins il doit y avoir une certaine idée
il doit avoir une certaine idée disons
que descente égalisent moi sur la route
il faudra faire d'autres
précis ou demi précis plus tard et c'est
égalise moi il faudra si vous voulez
marcher sur sur les œufs oui voilà
mais sinon tu veux pas relever sur tu
joues ok comme ça
on prend et C4 c'est pour ça que je
jouais donc
il a joué
non comme je vous ai dit j'aurais
préféré dans le social c'est fini
ça suffit peut-être maintenant
parce que sinon j'aurais peur de
d'Amadou MP3
et ce serait marrant qu'il fasse ça
ok donc de cette
ça paraît tellement logique j'arrive pas
j'arrive pas à comprendre l'avantage
blanc en fait où il peut être
dans ce cas là il y a pas d'autres idées
il faut alors
quoi que
si je fais un coup idiot
c'est vraiment rien ces quatre
on aura 8 par principe
non non mais c'était intéressant quand
même
ça va suffire
donc si alors tu rentres dans cette
cible avec ce 4 alors que tout bouge
peut-être sur terre je sais pas je sais
pas où est le milieu
la dame sur bois
soit plus tard sur l'île du roi et sur
que oui
H4 bien sûr H4 les deux je crois que
là je bouffe
je joue
toujours
bah écoutez
est-ce qu'il y a un truc comme ça les
blancs peuvent faire quelque chose ou
pas c'est ça la question enfin c'est ce
genre de position qui va avoir de toute
façon normalement non
normalement non mais ça a l'air d'être
vraiment égal même si les blancs peuvent
prétendre parce que le foot casse noir
est un peu mauvais mais il est pas
autant de m'envoyer si tu le ramènes par
exemple
oui puis même en fait on menace quand
même des seins et puis tu fais quoi en
fait tu fais des quatre il empêche ça
comment tu exploites ce fou qui est un
peu mauvais à court terme du radir en
plus les Noirs ils contrôlent la seule
colonne ouverte de l'échiquier c'est
quand même important
stratégique tu aurais les blancs qui ont
la dame en a deux la tour en a et la
tour en 8 ok on pourrait commencer à
parler peut-être côté blanc ok
c'est sûr que si je prépare un thé ligne
je les ramène
je ne soupirer des tu peux jouer ça
demain je connais les réactions voilà
vous avez quelque chose d'autre
parce que oui ça paraît pas être très
excitant
et c'est peut-être pour ça qu'ils sont
pas si dur les Russes
en tout cas là il a
il a une position étonnante il y a une
autre version par contre il est possible
que il veut juste passer cette partie
commence comme ça autant que tu partes
quoi
[Rires]
comme quoi si tu veux ils ont une bonne
idée
donc effacer maintenant se remettre
quand même et puis frappe fort avec une
des
vrais quoi pas comme celle-là c'est
possible parce que
il écrit ça il faisait ça ne compare pas
casse pas
oui mais bon ouais bon pas tout à fait
pour les mêmes raisons en fait oui bien
sûr le bouffonne bien sûr il va faire
dame de cette parce que c'est bon
issue les préceptes de muretas après
défaites nulles et le meilleur résultat
et c'est peut-être sa faute en fait mais
c'est vraiment pour se sent précepte
murtation ça dépend pour qui il y a des
gens qui tient bien de la tête après
l'air de fête il y en a assez beaucoup
d'air il y a une autre moitié qui arrive
pas à jouer correctement le lendemain
enfin au contraire quelqu'un fort donc
pour cela bien sûr vos milieux de ce qui
peut mais qui te dit qu'il va réussir à
mieux jouer demain après une telle nulle
tu te sens mal tu perds une game là tu
te sens mal ok mais juste fin
bah je mode c'est que les dignes de
terre
une partie tu es là oh je me
sens enfin ok juste ne viens pas en fait
laisse ta place oui moi je viens de vie
est là tu peux pas me parler quoi en
fait il a envie tant qu'il a pas perdu
quand il a encore perdu
je pars quoi
non je pense juste comment dire comme
l'expression de russe dit les grands
placards tombent plus fort disons que je
pense que il est tellement persuadé de
ses capacités
génial que une fois il perd je pense que
peut-être pour lui c'est pour lui c'est
plus pénible que pour les autres
[Musique]
quand tu dis placard tu fais référence
au bide ou à l'ego
je pense pas que son bide
[Musique]
oui c'est pour ça qu'il se relève
d'ailleurs
il se lève sur le podium
oui en fait
juste il est debout sur le podium
[Rires]
en tout cas sur ce qu'on va de ce début
de match si il a pas d'idée ici pour le
moment c'est quand même Ding qui aura
pris l'ascendant parce que Ding il s'est
relevé d'une défaite difficile il a
réussi à marquer
rapidement après il s'est repris et il
est dans son match quoi alors que Yann
ça sent la nul rapide dans cette partie
après peut-être qu'on rate quelque chose
et il y a toujours pas façon cool
il a fait tourin tempo en fait
ah bah comme on a dit tout à l'heure il
y a pas d'autres idées
alors maintenant donc les questions
c'est que il veut alors jouer la
symphonie de gaz branche
donc que vous allez voir sûrement aller
sur E3 et puis donc voilà viser
plusieurs cases sensibles à des 5 après
l'échange de faux
F5 G4 mais j'ai envie de dire sensible
dans les deux sens du terme en un mot
mais aussi en deux mots
parce que finalement il n'aura pas
beaucoup de cible
n'est-ce pas non mais si tu arrives au
bon moment sur G4 par exemple je parle
ils vont nous changer les fous j'ai pas
tout à 8 dans le 7 faut bosser juste
pour les spectateurs quand les femmes et
les Noirs font rien je vous fais les
couleurs
et passe son tour quoi parce que un
simple G6 en fait
que tu as de toute façon envie de faire
merci au revoir
non mais soit on se trompe complètement
ce qui est possible et il y a une idée
très fine qu'on voit pas ce qui est
possible soit c'est de la daubasse ce
qui fait dépôt or je pense que
sérieusement pardon c'est le réseau
logique comme j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure parce que les réseaux
neurologiques peuvent être très très
fort ici je sais de quoi ça parle et
donc et comme quoi
c'est toujours inter
mais c'est jamais 0 et 5 jours
niveau avec vos ordinateurs
moi avec mon turbine parce que c'est
comment comment les réseaux
neurologiques jouent de telle position
j'ai vu au jour ça et donc je pense que
c'est bien dans ce style
et on va voir on va voir si à un moment
donné bizarrement
dans ces cas-là rappelez-moi
rappelez-vous de ce que je dis
j'avais raison parce que
ici il fait pas parce que les premières
fois quand j'ai vu ce type de
préparation
j'étais hyper choqué
les gens aiment bien ton imitation des
réseaux neurologiques
[Rires]
flamande pense au tableau oui
c'est avec comment dire
ce chapeau là j'ai pas comment l'appeler
béret Berry comme ça c'est pain
G3
ouais ouais c'était bien ça
tu imagines que dans peut-être 20 ans
les réseaux neurologiques pourronter
à l'inverse est-ce que tu es un peu
suivi la
révolution de chat GPT
presque pas monsieur je suis les news
dans les news chaque jour ils disent
Étienne elles ont le réseau je peux te
faire un autre tableau de trempe de
Poutine de l'autre et c'était c'était
marrant
et d'ailleurs je voudrais bien une fois
faire comment dire faire un tampon avec
demander à faire un tableau je sais pas
mais tu peux ouais c'est assez facile je
voudrais bien
avec tu peux on va essayer de lui faire
la blague déjà j'ai pété il a mangé du
flageolet
je comprends pas la blague c'est des
petits haricots blancs ça fait péter
du coup j'ai vu un d'accord ok ok ok ok
finalement j'ai compris
mais c'est bizarre mais c'est bizarre
comme un homme pour le réseau pour un
réseau social pour une grande réseau
neurologiquement
bon tu auras vite ok on ne peut pas
vraiment se frotter que on a prévu ça
moi il y en a prévu ça et nous on était
sur cavalier D8 pour repartir par là
ou par là
c'est une grosse question
le cavalier par e67 comme ça comme on a
fait tout à l'heure ou peut-être juste
jouer débilement à cavalier
c'est quoi le problème
de blonde rajouter ce coup donc je joue
à le rookie et maintenant
qu'il est le problème après de 5 ah oui
e52e
non
d'abord j'ai pas vu ça
échanger jouer contre le pion E5
mais après quand je veux pas échanger je
connais F4 toujours qui
je suppose
alors
il faut modifier quelque chose
je comprends mais c'est quand même trois
coups pas de donc ça va pas être fait
c'est quand même trop de coup
mais bon tu auras 8 ça donne impossible
de faire pousser vite dans cette
position
voici chacun voit quand même se demander
le truc le problème c'est que les Blancs
contrôlent la colonne a donc sinon si
c'était pas ça bien sûr il faut celui
c'est automatique moi ici quand même les
bons contrôles
[Musique]
et je veux que les Franco le droit oh oh
comme d'habitude
par contre ce type
soit j'ai 6 ME peu probable
si la dame était sur ce 7 le coup
parfait aurait été collés
en me disant tu vas la première question
c'est dans le droit en fait et par
contre tu bouffes si Dame de 5 dames
et là par contre
tu bouges et tu menaces
ici
dans 3 et ce qui est important que voler
à 6 les 8
et le cavalier va dégager la tour et
défendre le tour sur la route
ok oui
je peux donner un exemple à quoi me
ressemble les stratégies de Brand de
cette particule
on peut commencer de le début la partie
fameuse
kasparo
2005 je pense son dernier tournoi en
France dernier tournoi où il a joué
comme
les trois que les six enfants
c'était ça leur partie et puis donc les
Noirs comme quoi on le contrôle de l'île
de dames
sur la taxe sur le roi et à un moment
donné était gagnant un moment donné
était gagnant belle partie de
donc c'est à ça que je compare pas
pourquoi parce que il est quand même
abandonné les colonnes ah ouais ah oui
pourquoi
je me suis jamais sûr
je pense
ok merci
et donc d'Alpha zéro a-t-on bientôt la
chance d'avoir la suite des master class
de Vlad est-ce qu'on a fini d'ailleurs
ou pas
fini quoi alpha zero non il en reste
encore trois épisodes et pourquoi on les
a pas fait
on sait
j'aime raison pour moi je veux pas les
ouvrir
oui oui il a une reste trois épisodes je
pense que je serais capable normalement
de finir les séries une fois le match
terminé un peu un peu on peut
d'ailleurs les trois épisodes les plus
importantes parce que je commence de
Louane les trois épisodes les plus
importants c'est les dernières
je dois dehors genre 90% du matos
et même si je garde jamais 15 % de toute
manière
de 2h30 3h ouais donc ça va être trois
gros épisodes
donc il reste
quoi après faut des 8 là
ok je pense que j'ai bien su expliquer
les raisons pourquoi elle n'a pas voulu
mettre le cogolais sur E7 toi tu m'as
interdit que de toute manière c'est rien
mais l'idée c'est que auprès d'embaucher
dans beaucoup de transfert du covoli sur
G4 donc
ça nous aide à comprendre l'idée de Ding
il vit au maître son cavalier sur des
sur d'abord
sortir vers B6 oh oui elle peut
ressortir vers B6
non non non non non non non
j'ai raconté c'était quoi les prépas
ouais mais il peut pas connaître encore
là
c'est possible que faut de 8 et l'une
des premières lignes dans ces cas-là
même ici il a fait des parties contre le
réseau neurologique
vous voyez c'est carrément artifice show
in the préparation aujourd'hui carrément
à bloc et on va voir qu'est-ce que ça va
donner en tant que les fruits plus tard
parce que mais pour qu'on est en cours
si pas l'éditeur au moins le chemin pour
encore
7 10 coups à suivre selon ma théorie
peut-être plus
mais c'est trop mais moi ce type de
préparation plusieurs fois en fait
ça marche bien généralement
non
capable de répéter tout ça sur
l'échiquier parce que si le mec fait ça
il faut faire comme ça s'il fait ça il
faut vraiment les enterrements ils
confond ouais tu peux pas
c'est beau quand même d'avoir une prépa
tu peux pas faire quoi
je pense que si il y a une pire
candidature pour ce type de prépa ce
n'est pas parce que on peut dire tout ce
qu'on veut sur lui c'est un joueur
brillant en tacticien très fort grand
joueur très dangereux etc etc moi une
chose on ne peut pas dire sur Oui il n'a
jamais été un joueur fin
mais là leur dit comment ça a aimé les
blancs un petit peu
avec
oui mais parce que
a été sur ifs
à 5 fois 6 ouais
il y a plus de rêve il y a plus de rêve
donc il faudra juste attendre comment
dire en anglais
[Musique]
ok merci
c'est là
de toute manière
l'opium blanc H va pas tarder de se
déplacer
sur H4 on va voir d'ailleurs un autre
défaut un autre défaut c'est que
quand tu joues H4
les Noirs contrôlent plus le casque
de mes pots peut-être contre quelqu'un
oui mais pas contre dingue c'est bizarre
quand même dans cette position tu aurais
le fond F6
tu aurais pu changer si tu ferais fouger
7 quoi
le Fou est mieux placé en baisse moi
j'aurais préféré
contre toi
ils ont su qu'il allait déconner comme
ça bah peut-être comme je vous ai dit il
a joué comme ça contre personne dont je
me rappelle pas de détails mais dans
chaque partie où personne ne lève
et donc peut-être ils ont analysé ces
réflexes et le mex je sais pas peut-être
mais le mec a des réflexes de mettre son
fous sur D8 et il a ses réflexes de
mettre se fout sur ce répète ça se
répète ça nous rend imprévisible dans ce
cas-là
que vous disent peut-être un jour comme
ça et ici il faut de 8 c'est pas top
et lui il va faire
enfin
de essayer de deviner qu'est-ce que
c'est passé
en tout cas
je suppose il a fait faux bêtise parce
que comme ça il pose une question de la
gueule
est-ce que tu es prêt pour ces quatre
parce que
ces quatre décès faut 3
baisser
tu veux rien là en fait
bah alors dans ce cas-là vas-y
[Musique]
est prévu
quoi que vous savez peut-être les noirs
peuvent s'en de ce que ce poisson
sur l'île de
non par exemple jouer au lieu de
domicile ce que normal peut-être un jour
à deux
j'en ai rien à moi
[Musique]
rien à quoi
oui
il n'a pas peur des
fantômes mais ça c'est vrai
des fois c'est même trop mais il croit
toujours à ses calculs ouais mais c'est
son moins fort il comprend que de toute
manière il comprend rien aux échecs donc
il doit que calculer ce qu'il faut à
merveille et donc
il croit ses calculs
très bien
[Musique]
si vous pensez que je ferai trop à un
moment donné je peux préparer une vidéo
pour Kevin je voudrais 50 exemples quand
c'était hallucinant ce que le foutu
positionnement parlant
classique mais après il calcule
tellement bien qui défend oui après oui
il s'en sort et tout mais la compression
mais vivre pas sur le même bruit quoi
même pas dans les mobiles quoi même pas
dans le même pays
mais
ces histoires de neiman c'est c'est fou
parce que finalement
on sait toujours pas la montagne
il est toujours 2007 alors peut-être
qu'il a triché dans certaines parties
réelles c'est pas c'est parce que j'ai
on n'en sait rien mais après il y a la
présomption d'innocence bien évidemment
qui existe mais je veux dire par là que
ils ont pensé qu'ils allaient le
détruire et le mec tient ses 2007
pas vrai dire j'ai pas trop de à vie en
fait parce que
Naka par exemple dans cette vidéo et la
moitié du coup c'est 5 tant que le fou
il sera 7
e
c'est que dans plein de lignes de piles
longtemps c'est le Premier League de
quoi se marquer de quoi se moquer tout
le monde doit faire gaffe parce que
l'ordinateur dit mais moi je le sais
depuis peut-être 5 ans que c'est souvent
les premières lignes de quoi c'est moi
qui ai eu euh
6 fois
moi je préfère exactement les mêmes
choses sur toi quoi que ce sera un peu
plus rigolo quoi
il a fait énormément d'argent avec cette
histoire mais
mais en tout cas pour moi ce qui a
toujours été étonnant avec l'histoire de
Niman c'est que je pense que si il
triche et on va mettre un gros si c'est
très très loin d'être le seul et dans le
petit groupe du très haut niveau il y en
a qui à mon avis on
peut dire quoi c'est très facile
ridicule en fait si il triche c'est très
facile pourquoi cette histoire est
devenue
[Musique]
notoire c'est tout simplement parce que
tu peux autrichir facilement il y a
aucun problème et comme ça pendant des
années surtout si doucement tu peux le
faire sans problème
c'est une seule règle de la maison c'est
un secret de la maison à touche pas le
proprio
il est méchant il est méchant il est
capable de tout les autres bah vas-y
vas-y aucun problème tout le monde va se
taire sur le sujet tout le monde va se
taire sur le sujet à mon avis ça a été
fait ma conviction personnelle c'est que
c'est fait de manière assez régulière
mais après
présomption d'innocence pareil que pour
Nîmes
non bien sûr le président
mais c'est pas un nom de le dire c'est à
magnos de le dire je suppose
mais après
tu as des choses extrêmement bizarres
dans les résultats quand tu vois les
parties quand il y a du délai pas de
délai par équipe individuelle tu as des
trucs les mecs jouent pas pareil en fait
tout d'un coup il y a beaucoup de thunes
le truc est pas trop contrôlé et les
mecs jouent comme ça quoi après c'est le
truc contrôlé il y a du délai ou les
équipes où tu veux pas tricher parce que
ça sert à rien les mecs jouent comme ça
quoi
ok mais c'est juste que il y en a trop
qui sont dans scénario là alors il y a
pas il y en a pas 100% qui triche mais
ok 0% ça paraît quand même aussi bizarre
n'est-ce pas
non non mais je comprends ce que tu veux
bon
je vois
quoi bien sûr tu peux jouer dans ceci
juste une autorité
mais il y a des gens qui parlaient de
l'idée de l'ordinateur qui était de
faire les H4 pour dame G4 dans le chat
dans le cadre et où est-ce que vous
allez
où est
ou ce que vous allez en se demande ça
suffit pas ouais c'est ça le problème
parce que les Noirs ont crié sur l'île
du roi comment on l'appelle
hérisson
il a des piques
mais ouais j'aime bien ton idée tour à
deux dame bet3 d'un Massy et damaka en
fait ça a l'air tellement
les gens veulent faire le problème dans
le chat c'est que vous voulez faire des
plans assez longs pour attaquer le roi
noir mais n'oubliez pas qu'on 3 coups
vous perdez toute votre aile dame vous
n'avez pas le temps de faire des plans à
la spasfit quelqu'un qui voulait faire
du G4 machin HK
vous n'avez pas le temps et puis vous
n'avez plus votre coup de casse blanche
aussi c'est une pièce qui vous manquera
pour terminer l'attaque
c'est dommage que les filles d'ailleurs
depuis longtemps c'est dommage que les
filles mais ne criait pas de de comment
s'appelle des petits Oscar rappelez-vous
qu'on voulait d'ailleurs je pense que ça
aurait pu te rappeler filet dehors je
sais pas quoi des petits prix pour le à
la fin de l'année pour la meilleure
prépa de l'année les meilleurs finales
de le meilleur tacticobo
déjà par exemple je sais pour
l'acier le prépare de meilleur prépare
de la neige je veux voter
on pourrait le faire on pourrait
remettre des kakis d'or à la fin de
l'année
par exemple moi en tant que l'un des
académiciens
j'espère qu'on va m'appeler à l'émission
d'accord comme moi
Oscar cinéma
comme
démission je j'aimerais bien faire les
recherches
proposer mes candidats et tout
puis grosse grippe de l'année oui oui ça
aussi il faut que ça dans une partie
importante
[Musique]
pourquoi pas
plus gros bide de l'année
il y a une grosse concurrence
[Musique]
très probablement d'accord
le grand leader quoi
oui la plus grande plus l'autre riz de
la mer tu imagines le niveau de Ding
dans les bits d'or
est-ce que ce serait pas le mec de haut
niveau le moins binaire
ah oui oui
[Musique]
en fait
en Chine quelque part dans les montagnes
du Nord il y a un musée des
révolutionnaires communistes
et dans ce musée révolutionnaire tu peux
tu peux manger le repas de communiste
qu'ils ont mangé pendant des années le
repas c'était quoi
un petit pois avec du riz plat quoi ça
fait partie
j'ai l'impression que donc Ding il est
sorti de cette musée là quoi tu vois
d'ailleurs ce qui est bizarre parce que
il vit avec une femme géorgienne et leur
cuisine est tellement bon que c'est
incroyable que les Sims
mais oui
il marche beaucoup tu as l'impression
qu'il y a deux i quoi
que le meilleur vin du monde il y a pas
si longtemps une année c'était un vin
géorgien et pas un vin français
d'ailleurs
technologie est différente c'est la
première nation au monde qui s'est mis à
prédire le vent comme ça c'est c'est pas
les Français les Premières nations du
monde
regarde après
8 ok en fait il joue c'est comme tu dis
c'est une prépa contre digue ouais c'est
que d'ailleurs toujours les meilleurs
prépas faut pas se préparer contre les
pièces il faut se préparer contre les
adversaires
c'est le coup qu'on avait donné en
premier parce que comme ça les Noirs
défend des 6 en avance mais peut-être
après dans votre marche toujours pas
quand même parce que ok ok
donc
alors dans ces cas-là comme après dans
23 dans ce 6 marche pas dans ce 6 un peu
de gens dire que c'est une mini foot
après tout
en fait ils sont très forts et très
faibles à la fois ils sont très fins par
rapport aux autres êtres humains parce
que ils font peu de grosse erreurs et
ils défendent bien pendant longtemps
mais ils sont très faibles par rapport
aux meilleurs ordis ça se font beaucoup
de d'imprécisions en fait ils font juste
moins d'erreurs et de gaffe
que le commun des mortel mais beaucoup
plus imprécision que l'ordinateur
est-ce que c'est assez pour que ce soit
gagnant pour les blancs non loin de là
encore mais tu peux commencer à être
non mais déjà après 1 2 3 les questions
c'est comment réagir parce que permettre
à 5
1 c'est c'est une question quoi parce
que éventuellement un jour que vous
voulez H4 que les 5 c'est peut devenir
une nouvelle fois j'aime bien la
conception de l'ordi mais ce que ça
passe il veut faire roi et fuite bon ça
pourquoi pas H5 cavalier
écouter je commence demande qui était je
commence de m'inquiéter sérieusement
je vous l'annonce
j'aime pas ce que
nous vient d'arriver on a sous-estimé
les roues coffres
je parlais du pire scénario non ok
comment dire
c'est des carrousel parfois
je m'inquiète maintenant je manquais
l'autre idée
peut-être moi qui après
comme ça elle défendent les cases C4 moi
je me pose les questions qu'est-ce que
ça donne si après dans votre tour à 4
les bons jours alors C4
oui je sais pas je pense que c'est une
question critique maintenant parce que
de toute manière elle va pas jouer c'est
pas la peine de l'analyser même dans
trois tour à 4 qui viennent c'est
vraiment la question est-ce que Yann va
trouver dans B3 mais ça a pas l'air trop
dur
bah d'un peu trop
B4 peut-être c'est pas tout à fait
grave
peut-être même bosser c'est pas grave
d'ailleurs alors moi il doit faire face
à ce cadeau ici cavalier de dos au moine
le cavalier se décale de c'est ça le
mode de Calais ce décalage de l'aile du
roi à comprendre ici
c'est pourquoi tu as pas disons si on
compare parce que ça tu l'as forcément
vu aussi c'est pas plus intéressant de
faire ça que tout a d'avancer ici si sur
dame MP3 tu veux tout à 4 ce que me
proposer de toute façon
tu es sur la table je suis joueur le
premier chose que je regarde ce tour à
deux et moi c'est sûr mais du coup
pourquoi tu choisis dame ceci sur dame
B3
comparativement tu auras 4 c'est un peu
con non si on est en comparaison
ce poste
ne marche pas ici
c'est quand même pas très dur non comme
variante ok ouais ils ont montré déjà au
cours de ce match que son droit son
droit d'être génie quoi
c'est quand même une variante forcée de
trois coups et demi quoi est-ce que il
veut pas jouer enfin non malheureusement
il y a pas d'autorité mais est-ce que
son idée c'est pas ça
malheureusement je pense pas ok il y a
une compensation c'est vrai parce que le
roi à long terme parce que la dame sur
B3 un peu logique en fait si tu as joué
dame c'est si c'est pour rentrer là
ok en gros l'idée l'idée c'est que si
les Blancs jouent
dans ce 3 il y a les deux peut-être des
retours sur 8 parce que B3 dans 25 km
C8
non mais là tu vois moi par exemple sont
mieux
oh ça commence le Power tu vois et parce
que c'est plus logique de rentrer
là-dedans en fait si tu suis le scénario
de la partie c'est beaucoup plus logique
qu'il est estimé que ça alors après il y
a aussi roi F1
oui moi dans ce cas là toujours tour de
8 tu forces 4 et tu joues F5 pour
avoir quand même l'accès
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est quelque chose
ah il doit pas être bien dépôt il doit
se dire oui j'ai vu tout à l'ordi mais
ça leur dit propose pas parce que c'est
pas la variante 1 ou 2 mais en fait
c'est beaucoup trop dangereux
pour son bide quoi
et peut-être qu'il va se jeter sur une
petite drone maintenant
[Musique]
[Rires]
petite
grosse
[Rires]
et les gars il adorait les drones
il est pas bien
il a dû il a dû voir le fou prend machin
qui avait carrément F4 il doit avoir
peur non c'est pas pour ça que ça quand
elle est assis comme ça le bide est trop
tendu donc parfois il faut être
le bide
[Rires]
d'ailleurs au lieu de ça ce que je
devrais mettre sur la scène au lieu de
sa photo
ouais ça aurait été beaucoup mieux
j'ai pas pris ils ont mis des gros plans
sur les nez comme ça et il est beaucoup
plus fou moi c'est pas grave
est-ce que ce serait pas l'heure de la
petite pause Vlad vu que ça va réfléchir
longtemps ici
voilà c'est exactement le moment et sur
cela on vous laisse ne quittez pas avec
le partenaire chez sarahma vous allez
voir la petite bande-annonce à tout de
suite les amis dans une dizaine de
minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les amis il y a eu il y a eu quelques
coups de jouets un petit peu étonnant
j'ai envie de dire puisque c'est pas ce
qu'on avait prévu mais après intéressant
H5 c'était quand même dans notre dans
notre règne de coups C4 et la D4 on
l'avait pas vu venir Vlad et c'est assez
intéressant il faut dire on en discutait
pendant la pause très intéressant il est
vrai qu'il en a pas prévu ça déjà il
faut comprendre qu'est-ce qui se passe
avec cette tension au centre
4 en premier
ça c'est facile oui sinon
E24
parce que ça va perdre une pièce
donc foot de 4 dame de 4 peut-être
ça donne pas les
quoique
OK et si je joue quelque chose comme
tour à deux
en gros je veux
occuper ta tour avec la défense sur
abado et après changer les dames dans ce
sens il est vrai par contre que mon
cavalier sur cette voiture horrible et
le Roi peut avoir du mal à sortir
de ça
alors non
non pas non plus
dans ce cas-là donc si donc on n'a pas
de CDD avec l'échange de dames sur des 4
dans ce cas-là décoller de cadres un peu
juste bouger la dame de squelette
littéralement sur E5 c'est mieux pour
les blancs ça et mon fou sur B6 peut
être hyper mal placé en fait pour
défendre les faiblesses sur je sais quoi
que ici je peux bouffer sur trois
dame de 6
que vous voyez F5 tu vas jouer dame de 5
moi je suis sûr de pouvoir sauver cette
femelle et ça ça devrait agréable sourd
et net mais je suis sûr de pouvoir
sauver ça ouais ça c'est sûr qu'il peut
sauver
donc alors
je joue ça alors
OK et surtout de 4
d'accord
maintenant
ma première réaction n'a été d'embêté
bien sûr mais sinon peut-être je peux
juste bouger de 4 parce que sinon
l'opium
pour trop longtemps oh d'ailleurs je
vais mettre je veux hyper ma tour par A5
donc je peux pas défendre
donc peut-être plus tard je vais pouvoir
le faire avec ma tour
au moins ça va rendre le genou noir
facile cohérent
un petit peu mieux mais on est en train
de essayer de comprendre à quel point
est-ce que c'est vrai ou ce n'est qu'une
illusion alors dit veut tourner 8 on
peut essayer de regarder aussi par
curiosité
ah non c'est pas jouable ça
non c'est pas un coup d'une guest
tu flippes trop juste non mais c'est
normal de flipper puis ça va pas avec le
reste ouais bien sûr c'est cool
pour l'instant je suis assez content en
fait ça va ça va
alors qu'est-ce que je veux auprès
d'ambassade s'il veut rien
ils ont tous deux
ils ont heureux
[Musique]
et je te demande qu'est-ce que tu veux
et dès que je bouge tu bouges quoi ouais
dès que tu bouges en cavalière je bouge
tout de suite
en plus dans certaines variations
mais je sais mais en fait ça m'apporte
rien ce que je veux dire par là
est-ce que l'ordi donne toujours le
meilleur coup non il peut se tromper
après ça dépend de la profondeur mais
surtout sur les petites turbines jusqu'à
profondeur 30 35 40 il peut se tromper
après il a pas toujours bon
par contre elle n'a jamais
parlé de ça quoi mais l'avantage
autant et assez grand mais bon après il
y a déjà 25 couches jouets quand même
bientôt 40 minutes 25 coups bientôt ah
donc il y a que 15 quoi à jouer c'est
pour ça que j'ai décidé de pas t'en
parler parce que j'ai l'impression que
le temps va pas jouer dans cette partie
bon de nouveau dans cette partie en on
voit n'est pas comment la cagnotte
tous les coups qu'ils connaissent sans
trop se faire la tête etc mais il a
raison que c'est une bonne
déjà je suppose que
sa constituait
l'une de ça a été l'un de ces points
très fort en fait que il est toujours
pressé sur le pendule parce que malgré
que parfois la qualité de secours
n'était pas
parfaite mais
cette pression sur le point de vue ceux
qui l'ont vécu ça qu'ils pensent être
chiant en fait
très chiant pour tout le monde je me
rappelle que parfois cette déstabilisait
même de des meilleurs joueurs
moi ça m'a toujours déstabilisé quand
l'adversaire est joué très vite
qui est au supplice dans cette partie il
arrive pas à
te préparer contre de tes lignes en fait
tu peux pas il y a des millions de télé
c'est carrément rien ou c'est peut-être
jouable mais tu vois jamais comprendre
ce que tu sais que ça existe OK
mais sinon bien sûr il n'a jamais fait
trop gaffe à cette ligne là ça c'est
évident
à faire gaffe entre guillemets
tu peux pas faire gaffe à tous les trucs
insignifiants
et on peut dire que cette façon de se
préparer a été introduit aux échecs sans
aucun doute par
il est vrai si on le style car pauvre
faisait ça souvent mais oui il improvisé
sur le chéquier en fait et n'hésitez pas
à la même époque aussi bien sûr
de jouer des petits petits avantages
minuscule mais analysant beaucoup avec
leurs ordinateurs et en connaissant tous
les unes et tous les autres
donc ça il est remises
et c'est vrai que maintenant donc ça
gagne les esprits des joueurs d'élite en
tant que les proches pourquoi dans le
chat tu as toujours des gens qui nous
cite ce que dit guéri alors qu'on a dit
exactement la même chose
mais du moment que c'est Guiri qui l'a
dit tu as l'impression que il a dit
c'était pas
[Musique]
non tout à l'heure elle m'a expliqué que
le pion n'est pas pris noble ni tout de
suite ni après Odin en fait ce qui n'est
pas trop grave parce que un n'a pas
réussi de voir trop de problèmes après
dès que l'éducateurs
normalement il est noir veulent pas
comme quoi donner laissé au bon endroit
de liberté mais ici il paraît peut-être
il faudra faire une ou l'autre
concession on peut pas juste
garder tous les atouts au noir non il
faudra permettre quelque chose parce que
l'idée donc
moi sur je sais que même bien très
présente
on va voir tour des 8 pagesjables
normalement si par contre s'il fait pas
eux des dame B7 je pense qu'il peut
perdre assez rapidement
à propos Kevin à propos de chat comment
dire
tu parles de Joe Biden
c'est pas vraiment bide
tu dis pas un danseur de quoi
notation que ça va être assez massif
à vrai dire tous les bolidens que je
veux ça a été toujours moi aussi
[Rires]
je me rappelle une fois à Cannes à noter
un groupe dans un restaurant
et puis donc
j'étais très impressionné par les
danseuses oui
il est parti aux toilettes pour se
changer je l'ai tendais près de
toilettes une fois elle est sortie je
lui dis bah fantastique votre bolidence
vu où mon accent et elle m'a dit en
russe
covid alors donc en fait elle se fait
bronzer le avec la crème
il y a une suite à cette histoire où
elle s'arrête ici je vois pas mentir non
[Rires]
donc il y a des quatre et sûrement dame
B7
il est vraiment pas bien
direct qui rejoue pas tempo non non
t'inquiète ça va pas tarder ça va pas
tarder si tu prends cette décision c'est
que tu as préparé ce cours non non
petite hésitation on va aller au fond
d'ailleurs il m'ose pas l'impression de
te bloquer au trop mécontent je pense
que il pense les mêmes choses que nous
que optiquement il y a un petit blimpro
moi au fond de choses pas vraiment
j'espère
est-ce que tu te parles intérieurement
pendant les parties quand tu calcules
genre est-ce que tu te dis ouais au
moins je sais pas quoi moi je parle pas
avec ma lèvres parce que oui il parle
avec les lèvres tu vois quand tu veux
jouer
toi dans ce sac mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que ça quoi oh mais il sait pas
jouer
quoi encore une fois mais quelle danse
pourquoi tu boudes les diagonales
en fait là maintenant de nouveau on
était tellement confiant pour Ding
il arrive juste par la jouer ouais
qu'est-ce qu'il est fragile tu reposes
un problème ça y est il explose
il est toujours en train de bouger ses
lèvres tu sais et tu peux même entendre
quelque chose de ce que je dis il touche
comme ça avec les yeux les chéquiers un
peu partout et les parle ouais
[Musique]
c'est ce que c'est un match de
championnat du monde ou un match que
j'ai entamé avec un gamin
oui le marmotte
ouais mais le problème c'est qu'il est
défendu donc
incroyable
mais il a réussi de détruire toutes les
pauses au bout de quelques coups
la seule chose dont elle se flatte c'est
que le Pione F2 sera en mer vas-y joue
dans 3 mois donc
si le mec joue comme ça bah je sais pas
si c'est la peine de te dire pour oui en
fait
je sais pas peut-être je veux changer du
camp
oui il est vrai toute ma vie jeter pour
Dina moi qui puis-je mais c'est pas que
je lâché je m'arrêtais d'être pour eux
mais je suis pas de j'ai pas commencé
d'être pour les autres
mais ici s'il joue de cette manière là
mais c'est pas dynamique c'est juste je
sais pas c'est
ils font plus grand chose ils ont un peu
disparu du foot je les suis plus au
dépit parce que c'était quoi la peine
là je dois faire les mêmes choses avec
Ding je voulais mais ils avaient un
entraîneur de génie non le dynamovski
dont les élèves a été j'ai pas les
moitiés des entraîneurs italiens tous
ces fables etc ce sont tous ces élèves
en fait
le génie pur dur et ils ont gagné quoi
de Fort dynamo kiaf deux fois champion
la Ligue des matchs et puis
championnat comme l'Union l'équipe de
l'Union soviétique a été composée
entièrement presque deux joueurs de
dynamo kiffe
deuxième place au championnat d'Europe
donc c'était le plus grand port mais
sinon quelque part vers
96 par exemple ils ont joué Barça à
Barcelone genre 4 ans je pense
c'est comme ça qu'ils ont des exemples
de l'équipe
je suppose je suppose enfin il était et
c'est qui pour toi le plus grand joueur
du Dynamo Kiev genre ton joueur préféré
mon préféré
enfin c'est un premier jeu soviétique
qui a signé un grand contrat avec
l'équipe
occidentale oui le signer avec je vais
qu'elle poste il était
milieu de terrain
il y a quelqu'un qui parle de Sergueï
rébroff ok c'est le tour de génération
ok il est pas mal il était pas mal il
est livré mais c'est l'autre génération
moi je suis plutôt pour cette génération
là d'avant
quand 80
97 FIFA a appelé la meilleure équipe du
monde en 86 pardon les meilleurs équipes
du monde
l'Argentine deuxième l'équipe du monde
pas l'équipe nationale
et l'URSS ça va aller quoi
par exemple 86 donc c'est les argentins
qui gagnent avec Maradona oui la
deuxième fois elle gagne 87 un tournoi à
Berlin
les ski donc de dynamique ils ont giflé
les Argentins 3 je pense et en Coupe du
Monde c'est quoi le meilleur résultat de
l'Union soviétique
ils ont fait troisièmes 4e demi-finale
oui mais il y a longtemps
il y a longtemps mais par contre en 86
quand l'Union soviétique a perdu au
compte les Belges 3-4
comment dire l'arbitre c'était quelque
chose l’arbitre c'était quelque chose
d'autre but c'était le obsède claire et
complètement colère et totalement courir
pour tout le monde donc il devait battre
les Belges même si les Belges étaient
pas bien mais plus fort
il était bien il était le meilleur goal
du monde peut-être deux fois peut-être
défilé d'ailleurs mais le problème c'est
que l'été du club
[Musique]
et pour moi Spartak
nous rapproche avec
quelque chose avec grichou aussi parce
que oui il est possible et bien sûr le
pire ennemi ce spectacle en fait le pire
ennemi c'est ce parc de tout le monde
c'est spartacte parce que dynamomo
Moscou c'est aussi Spartacus le pire
ennemi de tous les peuples qu'on peut
appeler les peuples descend
ouais c'est un peu comme le PSG pour
nous j'imagine non si tu es descends tu
es contre
toi
c'était beaucoup suivi le foot en Union
soviétique pardon c'était beaucoup suivi
le football en Union soviétique ah oui
mais parce que une autre fois
mais attends même par exemple tu te
rappelles l'équipe 88 88 l'équipe
Goulette writer
[Musique]
quatre joueurs fantastiques comment et
puis en quatrième enfin il y avait
quatre joueurs fantastiques mais c'était
les révolutions que les dash faisait à
cette époque là oui
on a joué moins bien
et dans les femelles on a perdu au
compteur
ee02
3 mosquées
et donc cette journée qui en a perdu
dans les finales contre les Belges c'est
carrément l'une des pires journal de ma
vie
et comment tu expliques du coup que la
Russie n'est pas du tout repris le
flambeau préféré
donc on va jamais réussir d'être aussi
bien techniquement que eux donc l'accent
d'aller préparations a été fait sur les
prépas physique prépa physique prépa
physique ou ordination entre les les
joueurs et ça marchait à merveille c'est
devenu un moment donné une machine donc
ce que la pression après de pendant ce
stage avec les les Italiens les Italiens
je pense que c'est aussi un peu la
théorie de Deschamps l'équilibre sur le
terrain en fait d'échange est vu une
interview d'un truc super intéressant
qu'un terrain de football c'est un peu
comme les échecs d'ailleurs que ce qu'il
y a un équilibre à trouver et que si tu
mets un mec à gauche tu dois
rééquilibrer avec un mec à droite
au niveau technique
il voit ça comme un
ouais le terrain c'est comme un jeu
d'échec quoi il doit pas y avoir plus de
poids d'un côté que de l'autre
par exemple quand on a demandé le ballon
au ski après le match dinama qui fait
écraser quelqu'un qu'est-ce que vous
pensez alors de vos élèves comment ça
s'est passé le match je pense que
l'équipe a bien réalisé toutes les
tâches techniques et physiques donnés
par mois avant le match c'était depuis
toute sa réponse en France ça a été
quelqu'un très calculateur très froid et
il philosophe
philosophe d'ailleurs en parlant de
l'obanovski avant le dash à vendre
c'est en fait oui qui a créé le concept
de totofoot juste de l'appeler
différemment
mais il y a il a écrit tout en oeuvre
dédié à tout ça et c'était avant donc la
création de ce qu'on appelle tout au
foot par les joueurs
mais en tout cas c'était c'était une
belle époque c'est vrai tu vois que ça
intéresse les gens dans le chat parce
que je dois dire que tu vois nous on
connaît pas grand chose en réalité de ce
qui se passait dans le monde soviétique
enfin ça je m'en suis rendu compte moi
en vivant en Russie bien évidemment mais
c'est vrai que c'est à l'impression que
c'était vraiment deux mondes
complètement séparés
et il y a beaucoup plus de personnes de
l'Union soviétique quand ils viennent
chez nous bah évidemment vous connaissez
bien l'Occident bah toi tu es français
donc c'est normal mais nous c'est vrai
qu'il y a beaucoup moins de gens qui
connaissent l'Union soviétique que
l'inverse tu vois ce que je veux dire
c'est l'Occident est plus connu en
Russie que l'Union soviétique en
Occident quoi ok pour un continuum
c'était quoi en fait à part de
régionalisme bien sûr il y avait une
grosse rivalité entre l'équipe
d'ospartag et l'équipe de dynamaki au
niveau de l'approche j'ai expliqué les
proches de l'abandon ski et l'approche
de Spartak a été comme quoi artistique
et alors bien sûr à la fin du compte
c'est le bonos qui qui avait raison
parce que si vous voulez c'est un peu
comme
botrinik a essayé de rendre les
ordinateurs plus forts en leur apprenant
les compréhension il n'a pas réussi même
si pendant longtemps le logiciel se
vit-il qui s'appelait Pioneer a été le
plus fort au monde mais après les
Américains ont gagné les compètes parce
que la zone a pris les ordinateurs
jusqu'à calculer calculer quelques clés
en gros c'était les proches qui au foot
voilà ici c'est pas le terrain pour
faire naître les Ronaldo quoi bah le
climat est différent donc que les lapins
courts quoi un peu comme un archevine
pour ceux qui connaissent le football
russe plus moderne pour que tu saches
[Rires]
le meilleur dribbleur tu vois
il est complètement nul quoi
relativement fort enfin à ce fort en
fait par rapport à Madame très fort et
quelqu'un a demandé Pelé quand quand il
était invisible quelqu'un m'a demandé un
journal quand est-ce que le suivi le
championnat du monde de foot tu connais
ces réponses non de la réponse de Pelé
quand les Brésiliens vont gagner le
championnat de hockey sur glace
[Rires]
mais c'est tellement vrai
excusez-moi juste une petite parenthèse
chez Kin le fou sur B6 tel que on le
voit maintenant c'est peut-être le
meilleur exemple de du fou qui est
faussement actif comme quoi elle est
surbussy c'est le contrôle le Diagana en
fait il est contrôle plus une fois les
dents oui sinon les questions du jour
vont être comment défendre le pion
surgissait et le papier en général oui
il est mal passé pour parfois quand tout
se joue sur un point clé quelque part
sur une faiblesse quelque part vaut
mieux devoir en vous passif qui offre
forcément actif non mais là c'est trop
il faut se rappeler de ce que tu
imagines la même position avec le pion
H4 le pion G6 c'est le fon G7
non mais
voilà c'est fou quand tu penses il s'est
foutu dans la merde tout seul quoi
ok déjà on connaît pas le résultat
on ne sait pas qui est-ce qui va arriver
mais déjà un peu dire donc attends il a
fait dame G4
et qu'est-ce que ça donne
ok si je comprends bien maintenant je
peux protéger mon
Adam sur ressemble
alors ok disons que l'autre essaie de te
frapper il y a tellement de coups pour
les blancs ici
ok disons le truc le plus
simple et basique je veux frapper ici OK
et je peux pas bouffer sur toi
tu protèges et je bouffe OK et là
[Musique]
entre tous les coups si tu veux
direct ok cavalier F3
OK
ça va et cavaliers F5
c'est pour ça que Game of Thrones
heureusement
lance pas jouer à l'autre mais pas assez
fondre avec mes potes il y a toujours il
est ni fin stratégiquement ni
physiquement
écoutez je suis tellement content que je
veux faire digne
il a fait dame 5
bon mais ça va en fait
ça va en fait ça le fait dans le cinko
ouais ça va tenir ah quel bol ah mais il
y a un truc qu'on a pas regardé la ligne
numéro 1 l'ordi parce qu'on n'a pas de
chèque ces dames des 7 oui en fait c'est
pas si clair
il veut tout prendre des quatre c'est
prendre des quatre
ah mais là il y a même dame prend parce
qu'il y a pas cavalier C2 on peut
prendre mais ça va en fait
ok c'est un gros bordel mais ça ça ouais
il y a ok juste des cinq le plus simple
pas première ligne mais simple
ça passe donc attendez Dame des 7 c'est
en fait c'est vraiment le couplet si
Dame des 7 passe pas on doit en être
sorti vous prend des quatre c'est
prendre des quatre dam prend des quatre
il y a dame prend le 7 donc non donc
dame prend ok il faudra aussi vérifier
d'ailleurs faut prendre des cartes
d'âmes B7
[Musique]
plombier de père en fils
mais t'imagines on sait rien de dingue
peut-être que son père est vraiment
plombier
sa mère
d'ailleurs sa mère est là-bas avec lui
je crois que je l'ai vu sur une photo
la mère de Ding je crois qu'elle est
avec lui je crois que j'ai vu sur une
photo en arrière-plan
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ça donne à fond que si je
bouffe même il y a des conséquences
tragiques ou pas si tu bouffes dans
votre
ok je bouffe pas non peut-être un jour
oui je joue même pas dans 6 jours
et là je commence à calculer
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que je t'aide un peu pour
qu'on avance je t'aide avec la
turbinette
ça donne envie parce que ça tape le roi
mais c'est vrai que dame F3 le petit
check sur la tour faisait très mal
il n'a pas compris qu'il peut attarder
un petit peu l'exécution
aux échecs
est toujours
plus importantes non non c'est toujours
plus forte que l'exécution
mesdamesis c'est aussi perspectif quand
même
ok ça c'est plus fort
[Musique]
non je sais mais même là en fait tu fais
rien avec les Blancs
tu t'es fait fermer en fait
si les Blancs n'ont plus de dés ici
c'est une très très bonne nouvelle parce
que j'ai peur que on est pauvres
va peut-être abuser à un moment donné il
va pas sentir le danger parce que
il est vrai si il est bon n'ont pas
obtenu de mettre
dans ce cas-là
mais tu sais ça j'ai remarqué souvent
quand on discute avec Étienne de ces
parties quand il fait des erreurs des
gros erreurs des parties de tienne des
parties des tiennes quand on parle de
ces parties quand il fait des grosses
erreurs c'est souvent juste parce qu'il
a pas la bonne évaluation je pensais
encore être mieux donc ce coup de va
être bon j'ai remarqué qu'il pensait
souvent en termes d'évaluation
oui bien sûr mais comme tout le monde
non mais oui bien sûr mais décision
dépendent de les voir
je pensais que ce coup donnait avantage
et du coup en fait comme c'était pas
mieux ben c'est l'inverse en fait je
vais être moins bien et c'est vrai que
ce que tu dis c'est que enfin ce que je
veux transmettre de ta pensée c'est que
si mes pots pensent qu'il a encore mieux
alors qu'il l'est pas il peut faire une
grosse connerie bien sûr
en tant que exemple regardons juste
qu'est-ce qui se passe après cavalier F5
dans le 6 cavalier 3 H 4 parce que c'est
logique
tu veux insister
mais si je fais juste ça
je vais dire que tout le concept de
Réunionnais le covalier sur
mais même ça en fait
enfin comment tu passes tu peux pas
hyper louper
ok tu as besoin quand même
tu sais que j'ai vu une partie
incroyable je d'ailleurs dans ce dans
cette position c'est très facile de
devenir moins bien que une fois les
Noirs arrivent de taper sur bredo je
vais pas ma chambre
britannique oxon il a flash son il a
fait un plan où il avait les Noirs mais
ce serait l'équivalent de rouage de
tourachin roi géant tour H3 pour
finalement insister cette tour
sur la moi je suppose que le reste était
fermé non mais tu pouvais pas empêcher
mais je veux dire par là que le plan est
beau genre ok tu peux pas passer par là
tu peux pas passer par là et tu insistes
quand même quoi si je vais passer vous
voyez donc ne pourra repris ses
anciennes
ah mais tu sais ce qui me fait peur quoi
le foufou peut penser que ça c'est bien
oublie
[Musique]
il peut faire non au please oui oui je
garde encore les doigts
peut-être on a de la chance l'ordi dit
que si tu fous la dame en dessin ça va
j'aime pas la gueule quand même
bien sûr
[Rires]
parce que c'est un joueur d'extin le fou
fou peut faire ça en fait prise et foodé
non il peut ça comme défense
en fait tu sais en fait
je pense de plus en plus que plutôt tu
vas gagner en fait
le fou fou
parce que à jouer archivite faire une
connerie pas possible une fois elle est
obtenue en gros avantage et continuer et
continuer à l'école pour se
compteur le mur c'est tout à fait une
époque on a gagné pendant des années
donc en fait le scénario me rend
légèrement optimiste dernièrement
là je pense que pour les pots il est
trop excité il y a qu'une solution pour
se calmer
je pense que ne pas répondre répond déjà
je pense c'est peut-être la seule chance
pour sauver en fait la seule que la
nature nous a gardé pour nous peut-être
qu'il doit juste se calmer en fait
et faire nul
trop excité par son avantage il faut
qu'il relâche la pression je pense se
retrouver
mais tu sais que je suis sérieuse
premier degré
[Musique]
ça
[Rires]
comment dire la solution de crise les
solutions de crise
cinq minutes
et là tu souffles
ouais mais parce que il est trop il a le
risque de trop surestimer sa position
il a déjà joué il a déjà joué
qui est là la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il
y a deux bonnes solutions soit tu prends
et dames des 7 et tu ramènes le fou ce
qui va trouver soit tu fais de la F6
attends il a joué là non où il a juste
bouger
il va jouer
est-ce que tu penses
qui bouffe la glace plombière
[Rires]
bon d'ailleurs la glace plombier c'est
les Russes en Chine elle est partout
c'est la glace que eux ils bouffe
maintenant depuis quelques années mais
en fait c'est français comme je
comprends
elle est plombier quoi
[Musique]
souvent le noir opticien pour tous 5 est
fou et fluide
les spectateurs comprennent que parfois
le fou peut être faussement actif en
fait
il a bouffé
ok retournons-nous
allez le plombier
le plombier plomb bleu
blanc
d'essai n'est-ce pas ferme les yeux au
moins 6 mois je joue parce que moi je
les mets sur
il
fait peur
il joue pas du tout là
bah j'ouvre les yeux alors
tu peux garder les yeux ouverts il joue
juste pas en fait
en fait
après tout comment tu te qualifié les
quoi comment tu vis toi
il est vraiment pas terrible alors il y
a qu'une ligne pour prendre l'avantage
mais je crois c'est pas trop dur en fait
OK dans mon coeur
en B8 quoi pour protéger le pur un peu
sur
en fait tu veux BK4 donc il faut
vraiment faire tout au dos pour empêcher
tu fais pousser 5
et pourquoi pas au lieu de retour 2 dans
le sang
des quatre
deux en fait tu as plus de coup avec les
noirs
en fait tu fais pousser cinq pour un
système et il te fait G4 et maintenant
il protège tout
il va te faire Rouger deux il va te
le cavalier en dessin qu'un jour
il te défonce en fait
je sais pas par contre les routes sur de
5 doit être
il a couru pour aller pisser
difficile tout deux bah pas tant que ça
en fait il menace B4
ok il faut juste espérer G4 B4 dame C4
que dit l'ordi puis on prend puis on
prend
ok il faut espérer que ça rentre dans un
truc comme ça mais même ça c'est loin
d'être clair non mais c'est trop ce
qu'il a fait quand même là non non un
truc comme ça c'est relativement ça va
quoi
et moi je monte les jours comme il faut
jouer tour de
faire défoncer en fait il y a le Fab qui
arrive juste à te faire défoncer et si
je trouve un moyen de l'autre d'envoyer
le pion là il fait fou c'est ça ok ça
c'est logique du coup il te fait G4 mais
tu vas jamais l'envoyer ton pied en fait
mais il est dégueulasse en fait lui
ok écoute je voudrais
[Musique]
qu'est-ce
pourquoi il fait ça
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas
je sais pas si c'est si clair
mais nous on jouait déjà le gars en fait
mais bon bah regarde
oui je sais pas moi je débarque en fait
j'ai pas trop heureux quoi dame F4
disons je sais pas
très très heureux
donc je vais déjà le gars en fait vous
voulez fou F6 c'est un jour
tu peux même
vite
ah mais ok j'ai pas droit
mais bon on était 13h
mais en fait le pire c'est que on était
pas mal ici aussi on pouvait faire juste
la mettre 6 direct l'autre option
ça allait quoi
bon après s'il veut que quand même il en
a un truc
et tu as faim
on jouait le gars aussi en fait on
faisait que jouer le gain partout et lui
il a fait le pire il a fait Damel 6
cavalier F5 pour prise prise
direct donc du coup
qu'est-ce qui je sais pas enfin bon déjà
je suis pas dans sa tête
qui avait peur de ça
mais bon
on est pas bien mais bon ok c'est pas
évident de prendre toutes ces décisions
sur des détails pareils
non le plus grave qu'il est fait c'est
quand il a fait fouder 8 cavaluer ça
évidemment au début
il pouvait juste jouer comme ça plutôt
ok ça je sais que c'est normal de faire
j'ai 6 ou 7 mais en fait il est déjà son
plan de jeu C4 je pense c'est la fin
tu vois la particularité
c'est pas le mieux mais du coup avec
Vlad on pensait que c'était mauvais les
gens nous ont dit guéri bon on s'en fout
un peu de guerre ici mais il a dit que
c'était le pire setup possible
j'ai 7 c'est ce qu'ils disent ce qui va
et moi ils te dis tout le temps que
que ça va pour les Noirs après je sais
pas moi j'aime
plutôt mieux pour les blancs avec
histoire de caisse blanche
en fait je sais mais
[Musique]
dans ce genre de truc j'ai joué genre
récemment la Reykjavik
en fait bon que j'avais les blancs vous
avez reconnaître le genre de position
même si c'est pas ça mais échec ça j'ai
fait à 4
mais bon ça me fait ça quand même
qui sont moches genre j'ai ok ça ça
tient un truc comme ça j'avais fait un
H3 un jour bon je sais plus quand
quelque chose comme ça
non j'ai attendu bon je sais plus mais
j'ai une position comme ça quoi
et je pense j'avais le client des deux
puis on C3 mais même ça c'était même pas
si simple tu vois regarde l'ordi il
donne 0 16 seulement
alors que bon moi je
[Musique]
me dis que je suis très bien quoi c'est
fou qui revient je vais donc cavalier
enlever la tour passer en F1 ici
bon ok bon j'ai gagné la partie mais pas
pas grâce à l'oppression je suis bien et
donc en fait juste j'en sais pas je
comprends rien et c'est comme ça mais
visuellement j'ai toujours l'impression
que c'est mieux pour les blancs mais les
ordis te disent qu'en fait non mais en
fait ce qu'a fait une époque
que c'est un peu le même truc comme ça
il trouve tout là c'est trop il joue
bien
mais du coup aujourd'hui c'était un peu
un même rapport et ça pourrait être le
même truc mais
[Musique]
après si on écoute de diagnostic de Vlad
sur le style des joueurs c'est que si
c'est le genre de position tu es plutôt
pas passif avec les Noirs
peut-être pas très bien mais
je sais pas trop c'est 5 jouets mais là
j'ai
trop logique j'ai 4 tu protèges tout et
tu vas monter la position petit à petit
je sais pas si votre
ouais
rachmaninova et moi j'ai fait une partie
d'elle aussi elle a perdu une superbe
partie contre
c'est sûr là en fait c'est trop facile
moi je l'aurais fait très naturellement
tour aux deux j'aurais eu du mal mais
j'ai 4 j'aurais fait très naturellement
j'aurais commencé par G4 en fait moi
je me mets sur casse blanche avec le roi
je protège tout j'ai des idées de f4g5
un jour je sais pas pour moi c'est mais
bon c'est un coup de blitzer aussi chez
4 non non mais ça va c'est solide qui
tient tout tu as pas de faiblesse mais
peut-être il va falloir prendre son
temps en fait l'alien
non mais du coup ça devient de plus en
plus logique quoi si tu as besoin
d'absolument défendre F5
et
là c'est hyper dur
j'aime bien la ligne de l'ordi
d'ailleurs elle est hyper instructive
dame D8 qu'on menacer des 5 et Dame des
seins
elle est parfaite mais personne n'enlève
et elle est centrale elle est bloquée
sur l'échiquier quoi non mais je veux
dire en plus tu veux dire top tu vas pas
perdre de temps quoi donc elle est
parfaite mais elle rayonne au milieu
je serai Catastro fait de la position
là il va se faire défoncer
ouais c'est pas facile mais
bon je sais pas moi c'est plutôt une
bonne partie de nez en fait dans
l'ensemble mais
en fait disons il a ce pourquoi il joue
depuis le début
il touche le point faible quand tu fais
fouger 5 fois
le plan bah ça peut être après G4 Dame
des cinq et des deux rois G2 F4
peut-être cavalier 4 puis un jour j'ai 5
F6 et mat quoi enfin par exemple j'ai 5
G6 ou en fait tu contrôle toutes les
cases blanches ouais en fait le problème
c'est le fou bon qui est déjà mieux que
ce qu'il aurait pu être mais qui a pas
de vrais cible en fait bah si tu enlèves
ton roi et que tu enlèves le Pione en
fait il a vraiment plus à rien
neymar au PSG
ouais
il est là mais on sait pas trop pourquoi
peut-être la prochaine partie sera plus
fort
changer de club
ouais après ouais je sais pas donc
peut-être ouais pas bien mais
peut-être soit mal jugé ça Ding oublié
G4 un truc peut-être je sais pas c'est
dommage
je pense qu'il doit peut-être même
tenter juste des quatre laisser le pion
s'activer ouais
mais il s'active pas trop en fait
mais j'ai quasiment plus envie d'avoir
un pion devant là dedans que d'avoir
égalité matériel dans l'autre bon après
peut-être tu peux le faire un jour ou
l'autre mais bon
qui est
on se fait déjà maté bon du coup
peut-être pas partir trop loin avec la
tour
peut-être faut pas s'activer du tout
quoi
ouais c'est dur
ah il a pas du tout senti la position
dans cette partie
dommage et si on
est 18h
bon pourquoi pas enfin mais bon et si on
fait des salles d'abord on va faire un
coup
en fait ça arrive
je sais pas dans quel sens
et parce qu'on a vu que les tours il y
avait des réseaux de maths
donc échanger une paire de Tours pour
limiter le
le jeu offensif des blancs maintenant
[Musique]
donc pour tout revête et donc là OK
c'est terrible non non
j'ai aucune vérité je veux juste faire
nul
ok c'est visuellement en fait tu t'en
rends pas compte et puis tout d'un coup
quand tu commences à regarder
concrètement t'as pas de coup non c'est
un peu chiant
ok bah pas tout va vite
et admettons
alors on se fait dégommer par camaïeu 5
[Musique]
quelque part
ok ça c'est dur
il faut bien juger
après ça se voit que cette finale elle
est cataclysée
[Musique]
mais quand même mais en plus ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'il va pas trouver en
fait pourquoi parce qu'en fait sur pion
prend
réussir justement avoir des cinq étoiles
il a fait de la meuf 6 dame F4 dans le 4
pardon de sur B8 ça ok c'est pas pour
faire Dame des 8
ouais en même temps mais bon il nous a
montré l'autre jour que c'est faire donc
si il se rend compte qu'il a fait le con
il peut rechanger d'avis
non mais en fait bon malheureusement
pour lui c'est je comprends ce qui t'a
envoyé pour faire B4 mais ça passe pas
du tout quoi
et l'autre dame de 8 enfin je veux dire
ça faisait quoi ça
c'est plus ou moins le genre de position
mais bon
F4 et là en fait tu replaces ton fout
sur F6 le fameux truc en fait tu as
juste la même mais honnêtement mieux
c'est vrai il est pas mal pour jouer
avec B4 hein ça fait penser aux
Marshall de Carlson contre ola même
peut-être des joueurs
5 aussi enfin en fait c'est
en fait ouais bon ok maintenant c'est
clair mais il a joué je peux comprendre
que pendant la partie dame David bon par
contre ça c'est une grosse qualité de
Digne quand même qu'il faut souligner
c'est qu'il est capable de complètement
se tromper de faire fausse route et de
revenir
et ça c'est une grosse qualité c'est
vraiment pas facile à faire
intellectuellement mais il y arrive dans
toutes les parties alors on doit c’était
mal passé mais c'était déjà trop grave
là il est moins bien mais
c'est moins grave que l'autre jour quoi
est-ce que Fab on ferait pas une pause
maintenant
bon si tu veux moi je meuble je viens
d'arriver j'ai pas besoin de fin je peux
faire pour moi mais ça fait un quart
d'heure
5 je pense ça peut encore un peu
réfléchir mais Ding va commencer à jouer
vite ouais bien sûr sûrement on fait une
petite pause
je parle avec le chat
si jamais
le coup logique parce que dame D8 faut
le faut pas oublier que les normes
menacées d'avancer
et pourquoi pas d'avancer
du coup
du coup ouais Dame des 5 normal bloc et
une très bon bloqueur à la main dans
cette position et
tu penses qui veulent changer
je connais pas je connais même pas les
joueurs quoi je sais pas s'il y a un
haut Connor qui joue ou pas ou si il
joue plus mais au Sullivan n'importe
quoi ouais mais je suis resté mais ouais
bah à part lui en fait en gros voilà
[Musique]
à part lui je connais pas quoi
du coup j'ai pas un grand
sauf que j'ai pas suivi la saison bon je
sais pas la saison fin sur tard battu
j'ai pas trouvé les matchs mais j'aurais
plus trop bref
football ski alors je connais pas le
site je connais le compte Twitter
alors ok on me dit que c'est c'est
égalise facilement
ok bon c'est intéressant si c'est parce
que le peu qu'on a regardé Kévin ça
semble bien pour les blancs bon
basiquement le problème c'est que il
fait BK
[Musique]
il faut le comprendre ça
en fait de prime abord bon là où on
avait fait fausse route c'est que je
sais pas si tient ça et est-ce qu'il y a
pas moyen de s'activer je sais plus quel
coup de merde j'ai dit un coup de dames
mais en fait on se fait contrer avec les
Blancs qui investissent la 8e et donc ça
ça mène à rien bon ça c'est on peut le
comprendre tant bien c'est un coup
d'épée dans l'eau c'est juste regarder
chèque parce que regardez chaque quoi
comme d'hab mais ça donne rien et alors
du coup faire ça maintenant
[Musique]
OK et genre après bon je sais pas juste
un coup
c'est vrai que l'absence des pions genre
si je reviens et je fais rien ça laisse
un passage tout d'un coup on se fait un
peu
on a un peu plus fragile peut-être
[Musique]
ok bon je vais rien faire juste regarder
ce que ça donne
bouffe et pourquoi ça c'est
genre
ça change tout parce que tout à l'heure
on avait genre de position avec
[Musique]
genre je veux dire
si je passe mon tour je m'installe
bon je vois que le module même ça il dit
qu'il y a dans ma carte
ok bon
bah ok on sait au moins qu'on est noir
de jouer donc c'est connecté au plan
avec Dame D7 et 38 mais il faut filmer
un pion pour s'activer
pas facile mais bon ça du coup on est
moins bien on a vu et ok
on peut jamais jouer des seins G5
j'imagine pas le côté blanc
on peut on a vu une vente comme ça tout
à l'heure là juste en prise pour
l'instant il défend trop bien
de prendre du cavalier ça peut être
chiant parce que ça va attaquer
peut-être lui peut rebondir peut se
passer deux trois trucs
non mais ok
peut-être qu'il va trouver par
comment dire bah en trouvant qu'il est
mal qu'il est mal qu'il est mal et par
élimination des lignes quoi mais
franchement c'est dur
en gros probablement qu'il faut calculer
ça comprendre qu'on n'est pas bien et
qu'on bouge pas une oreille et du coup
comprendre il faut faire la même avec la
disparition de ces pions là
bon facile à dire
le goût c'est B4 du coup
a priori pas facile
pas facile du tout
mais par contre que les Noirs
comprennent qu'il failli jouer de
manière assez dynamique dans cette
position et concrète pour pas laisser
les blancs manœuvrer sans qu'on comprend
bien parce qu'en fait c'est vrai que si
on fait rien les blancs ils vont prendre
leur temps peut-être 3g2 je sais pas je
l'aime bien peut-être que ça sert à rien
ce coup mais je m'enlève du vis-à-vis et
je suis proche de défendre mes pions
le cavalier va commencer à bouger on va
attaquer là on va toucher lui peut-être
on arrive si c'est un moment pour pour
affaiblir ou avec lequel il a peut-être
apprendre un F4 G5 et on avance donc
ouais en gros c'est énorme passent leur
tour je peux juste illustrer ce que je
raconte comme ça ce sera visible pour
tout le monde mais si on a une position
comme ça
bon même si on peut déjà peut-être
prendre ça mais en gros F4 G5 F6 vous
voyez bien que que ça va pas que même ça
ça doit être fort parce que on casse les
pions et puis j'en sais rien on a la
dame qui débarque
et où lui enfin bon donc ouais en fait
en gros le scénario comme ça et ne
peuvent pas le tolérer quoi et on n'a
pas grand chose à opposer je veux dire
objectivement c'est vrai qu'on se dit
bah merde je bouge pas je sais pas quoi
faire et donc ouais filer le pion pour
tout d'un coup s'activer
ça peut prendre forme dans le
raisonnement quoi
bon pas évident mais
BK
c'est bien possible parce qu'il aime
bien s'activer Maxime il n'aime pas les
positions passives à souffrir et toute
façon je pense enfin on peut être
nombreux à y penser après bien l'évaluer
ça c'est ça la difficulté en fait
après je sais pas s'il manque de temps
pour pour BK
voilà en gros si vraiment il voit zéro
contre je nulle part il peut peut-être
le faire mais faut vraiment connecter B4
à Dame de cette Tor 8 c'est ça qui est
pas évident parce qu'en fait tu fais B4
trouve ta colonne bors ta tour qui est
dessus et en fait justement c'est pas du
tout pour l'utiliser c'est pour partir
là-bas parce qu'en fait tout pour plus
le jeu pour finalement ta dame à la fin
que pour ta tour mais c'est ça qui
conceptuellement est quand même pas
simple quoi je trouve
donc
avoir
on va voir s'il trouve
mais ouais mais du coup ça a priori
peut-être que ça s'était pas ouf j'en
sais rien mais toujours est-il ici ouais
a priori c'était vraiment le bon
placement de pièces comme ça et que ça
c'est un peu le tournant du moment où il
a eu vraiment des problèmes objectifs
alors même si maintenant a priori leur
dit les bonnes ordi je veux dire ils
tiennent avec les Noirs ça devient plus
trop simple enfin c'est à dire qu'on a
plus trop le choix c'est il faut faire
le bon choix maintenant et plus se
tromper alors peut-être qu'avant il
avait peut-être le champ de trois quatre
possibilités j'en sais rien
donc c'est vachement plus dur
niveau pendule ouais plus que 20 minutes
alors ça va en fait on est déjà en train
de quatrième coup mais
[Musique]
bon ouais il peut en grave cher bon
moment quand même
c'est peut-être le tournant de la partie
bon il a bien raison surtout que c'est
c'est KO
il y a pas les 30 secondes par coup là
donc c'est vraiment t'as plus que
quelques secondes ça consiste tendu quoi
mais là ça va il est large avec 20
minutes je veux dire il pourra bien
afficher encore un quart d'heure si
d'une série de coups je veux dire il a
quoi il a 7 couilles il en fait un il en
fait deux et on fait trois
bon c'est pas les blancs font un coup il
va faire 4 où il va faire 4 ou je sais
pas un truc comme ça et après il y a
plus de 3 à jouer donc il peut enchaîner
c'est juste il va pas juste faire un
coup il va il va nous jouer une série
alors il a fait en fuite
je sais pas il me semble qu'on en a
parlé de ce coup alors je sais pas
c'était la petite turbine mauvaise du
coup qui disait ça ou si c'était un vrai
coup correct
en tout cas c'est pas la recommandation
de CC
qui était avec bé4 et c'est peut-être
une faute
mais bon comme comme dit c'était pas
facile du tout de trouver la
[Musique]
bonne défense
et après je sais pas à quel point ça
défendait enfin ok peut-être l'ordi d'un
égal et après je sais pas en pratique
aussi mais
le peu que j'ai vu ça avait l'air
vraiment pas con quoi
ok donc F8 il est blanche ici ranger
deux ouais alors ranger deux c'est pas
mal ça a un coup de consolidation en
fait je sais pas tellement une idée en
soi mais c'est juste on s'enlève des
échecs on s'enlève du vis-à-vis du four
donc on déclou le pion aussi pour la
lancer plus tard on peut monter comme je
disais si lui il attaqué un jour ou quoi
on se place bien pour les finales si
jamais elles arrivent le roi qui a une
sorte de voile lactée donc finalement ça
améliore sur plein de points la position
et
on dit au nord vous faites quoi parce
qu'en fait ils ont pas trop de
kumanjouets le problème de dame là
parce qu'on veut faire ça c'est que je
sais pas on a vu tout à l'heure il y a
un problème avec qui sautait
[Musique]
bon là c'est juste concret mais c'est
pas anodin enfin moi il y a un club j'ai
un collage ça c'est pas invisible et sur
dame là on a lequel il vient
et on avait vu ça un truc comme ça
déjà ça change j'ai plutôt recette quand
même mais ok peut-être qui est Mb4 ou
qui avait dit là force l'échange des
dames
et travailler cette finale problème
final ouais c'est que elle doit gagner
elle doit gagner parce que bon je suis
pas déjà si on fait 6 maintenant
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
en fait dans ce genre de truc
bon peut-être je peux aller le prendre
maintenant mais peu importe enfin je
voulais juste illustrer en vous montrant
un truc comme ça c'est que ça en fait il
y a un trois contre deux de ce côté pour
les Noirs il y en a trois comptes 2 pour
les blancs de ce côté mais c'est pas la
même valeur quoi dire que lui c'est
comme s'il était pas là quelque part les
blancs ils peuvent créer un pion passé h
facile et ils ont le droit qui peut
aller là-bas
attaquer les pions donc il y a trop de
faiblesse chez Nord il y a deux front
quoi enfin il y a les pions faibles et
il y a il y a le fait qu'il va falloir
surveiller les pions quoi donc ça se
fait on peut pas rentrer là-dedans avec
les Noirs la finale est trop mauvaise du
coup rentrer là c'est un côté très
pénible pour les Noirs c'est qu'ils
peuvent pas lutter pour la colonne donc
on va rentrer il s'active pas échanger
les tours c'est perdant et donc en fait
ça c'est un vrai problème j'ai envie de
dire c'est un vrai problème que on n'est
pas le plan avec Dame des 7 tours là
avec ce cavalier qui débarque
[Musique]
bah du coup je sais même pas trop
j'aime pas trop le plan Ding alors
peut-être ça recommence qu'on peut faire
un B4 mais
ça rentrait pas trop dans le cadre enfin
si ça se trouve ce jouable j'en sais
rien ça reste peut-être la seule chance
on va dire je sais pas je veux un truc
comme ça
mais
je sais pas ouais en tout cas si
l'affaire c'est normalement il est pas
sur la piste de Philippe pion quoi
et je suis même pas sûr ce sont encore
une bonne idée pour le coup ça marche il
y a un coup ici a priori de faire ça
comme on disait et dame là pour toi et
peut-être que le simple fait que le roi
soit ici des fois on a des damacates
pour attaquer mais avec Laura ça se
trouve ça va plus passer qui va avoir
des petits détails qui qui change tout
donc on va voir c'est ce que je joue
n'est pas
voilà moi j'ai deux ça fait pas grand
chose enfin ça améliore juste c'est pas
mal déjà d'améliorer sa position et
peut-être qu'il a plus
faible tu vois qui gagne cet aprèm entre
Bordeaux et Metz
bon match serré c'est de la Ligue 2 et
c'est de match pour le pour la montée
important plus important pour Metz j'ai
envie de dire parce qu'ils ont 4 points
de retard donc en gros si bat pas
Bordeaux
ça va être dur pour eux là c'est un peu
leur shot donc ils vont être très
motivés mais Bordeaux c'est ça à quoi
s'attendre et après je sais pas comment
ils vont gérer la tension quoi Bordeaux
a déjà eu un match comme ça à Sochaux je
crois qu'il y a quelques semaines vous
avez fait nul donc je sais pas
j'aurais tendance à
si je devais parler enfin bon c'est
chaud j'ai tout peut arriver
mais bon si tu me demandes comme ça
j'irai plutôt côté Bordeaux mais
bon
là franchement je sais pas
d'échec ou de Ligue 2 OH sur une ligue 2
sûrement de Ligue 2
pardon je regarde surtout que c'est un
thé mais je suis quand même les
résultats et je vois un peu ce qui se
passe au classement quoi
[Musique]
ouais mais là je suis plus objectif non
mais là c'est un thé c'est remis à jouer
pas si mal alors après bon si s'il
reprenne un peu la grosse tête et qui
font plus les efforts ça évite des
chanter mais s'il joue comme le faire
une idée d'un dernier match
peuvent très bien gagner enfin je veux
dire j'étais au stade pour le match
aller contre Grenoble il y a eu deux ce
n'est pas impressionné Grenoble mais bon
je vois qu'il faut leur saison ils sont
en 6e
donc ouais enfin il y a pas d'argent de
faire les malins avant d'aller là-bas
le retour de keV
il se passera rien de spécial ouais donc
il a fait en fuite
[Musique]
c'était plus B4 d'après donc c'est c'est
quoi
ce que je te disais en fait
d'intuitivement sans voir cesser la
petite turbine donnait pas mais c'était
l'idée de bah il faut faire un truc
actif en fait sinon tu vas mourir
tu vas crever en fait
mais ça se voit en fait tu es en train
de crever là
bah ouais alors je sais pas quelle idée
peut avoir Ding parce que il doit le
sentir quoi enfin c'est sûr
il y a les vidéos d'ouverture sur la
chaîne blitzrim facile qui sont
intéressantes celles qu'on a fait
ensemble les enjeux des ouvertures
ces vidéos c'est juste de voir un peu ce
qui se passe ça vous fait pas un
répertoire mais en gros vous comprenez
plus ou moins un peu les ventes qui
existent peut-être les structures pion
potentiels de trois objectifs de la
position et voilà mais c'est déjà bien
en fait sur les six cylanes par exemple
elles sont un peu plus poussées parce
que la structure
quoi on a mis ta partie contre
l'Espagnol ouais j'abuse
donc
on a vu une ligne tout à l'heure ou
après Dame des 7 tours 8 il y avait un
échange de la part entrer en D2 donc F1
en réalité moi j'aurais dit plutôt
logique de ce qu'on a vu
et aussi il y avait d'autres lignes que
Fab montré avec des enfin avec un
clouage mon état il montre un cavalier
français 6 dames français si c'est pas
dame F7 maths à cause du clouage et
d'ailleurs moi j'en profite pour dire
que vous pouvez aussi suivre la chaîne
de chascom fr sur Youtube je sais qu'il
y a des petits trucs qui s'ouvrent des
fois sur sur le chat
tu veux cliquer tu peux suivre aussi
dans la tronche en fait et que ça marche
jamais dame C8
alors autre truc important c'est que tu
as peut-être 6
alors recette j'imagine
différence quoi
l'idée de dépôt il y a aussi ça il y a
quand même pas mal de trucs
on a plus trop le choix
dame 4 pour rentrer
cavalier H4
ça me déprimerait mais une puissance
mais l'ordi
peut-être on a ça mais j'aime bien le
sauvetage de l'ordi
OK
ça c'est un peu relou en fait tout va ça
va toujours être relou mais ok enfin on
est pas mal déjà
fait une structure sa structure est à 5
et D5 enfin il y avait un pion à 5 et en
D5 contre un pion à deux comme ça et
c'était une finale j'ai mon cavalier ma
tour qui a attaqué le roi pareil et le
mec à un moment il m'a fait D4 puis on
prend bon il a repris et B4 C3 C21
mais je veux dire par là que là tu
pourrais imaginer que ça crée un contre
jeu en fait maintenant ce truc là oui il
est pas bloqué en dessin comme
ok bon écoute on va voir
mesdames C8 pour dame B7 ça paraît être
le ouais en fait tu profites que le roi
soit pas en G2 pour taper sur la
diagonale et forcer les changes non
oui mais je vais en fait tu profites
d'un peu tout mais oui c'est possible
que nepo est envie de faire C6
ouais mais avec enfin
quitte avoir un truc relou je préfère
que il se passe des choses pour les
noirs et du coup en fait je sais pas moi
j'ai deux c'est pas c'était juste le
placement que j'avais intuitivement ça
ça marche plus ou c'est la même chose là
il te dit quoi juste comprendre
F6 j'imagine si on prend je vais voir ce
que ça change
ah parce que dans l'autre il te fait
d'accord et dans l'autre éclorean
H4 il fait plus d'un B7 quand même vas-y
je veux voir ce que c'est pas
d'apprendre tout reprend F6 GF qui
relief-5 il y a une gif mais je vais
voir la canne dessin
[Musique]
mais peut-être un moment donné ta roue
f3k3d 5
si c'est une DIF
mais très dur à comprendre mais je veux
dire peut-être par bol il rentre là
dedans et c'est moins grave
oui mais bon
quand même
on peut montrer un truc qui me fait
plaisir
c'est pour montrer des maths les gens
aiment bien quand on monte des maths
généralement vous aimez bien quand on
démats ou ils sont très heureux parce
que là ils comprennent en fait que c'est
la fin de la partie d'évaluation à
donner ou d'expliquer pourquoi c'est
fini et là c'est fini le droit un peu
plus bouger et les champions se sont
très heureux
ils sont heureux bah ils aiment bien
avoir des maths en fait
tu veux que j'en montre un autre
[Musique]
fait tout recettes bon et là il prend
pas et là il prend pas il fait euh
madame
ça c'est du commentaire quand même un
petit peu qualitatif et celui-là tu peux
tu peux l'améliorer ce commentaire
la jolie
là on comprend mieux on comprend mieux
damash 3 roi E2 tours 8
tiens voilà là les gens comprennent de
quoi on parle là les gens sont là c'est
intéressant ce que tu dis avant l'autre
qui était avec toi tout à l'heure il
était con il a raconté des trucs
après je sais pas un petit peu torcer 7
et coulisser la main pour cette recette
il me dégoûte
c'était pas trop dur quand même
ouais après je sais pas ce qu'il y a dur
c'est que tu es égalise quand même pas
et en fait
et il y en a certains qui sont un peu
moins mal que d'autres mais c'est dur de
juger quoi je sais mais bon il dégoûte
quoi tu dis vas-y trouve un coup une
fois quoi bah il veut rien qui veut te
lancer ça tu vois attends disons le coup
de l'ordi Toro 4 juste pour comprendre
en fait
[Musique]
tu fais quoi
ah ben je vais monter mon roi bah moi
j'aime bien la manger
trop bah je reviens je bouge mon
cavalier en H4
[Musique]
mais là je peux faire des trucs
maintenant
je viens là
je sais pas mais
c'est toujours pareil pas si simple
j'imagine comme ça
mais ouais est-ce que ça peut être un
plan de défense juste de rien faire
je pense pas
non mais surtout en plus là
peut-être c'est une idée
il se fait dézinguer
quoi
on va voir si ce qui fait quoi
ouais c'est déjà vu des parties
célèbres
incroyable c'est ouf Anderson contre
Batman
et c'est incroyable il a gagné avec les
Noirs quoi mais
il a juste rien bougé mais au début de
la partie quasiment quoi tu as de la
position des blancs entre le coup que
genre 15 et 30 ils ont tout amélioré
l'autre il a rien fait et je sais même
pas comment il a gagné mais mais
peut-être on la fera en vidéo tiens il a
rien fait je te jure il a rien fait il a
gagné
c'est beau
non mais ok c'est juste incroyable quoi
parce que en plus ou le fond d'arson
c'était vraiment un beau joueur quoi
mais c'est juste non mais ne rien faire
c'est peut-être très fort en fait aux
échecs parce que tu détériores pas ta
position
mais tu as vu comment l'ordi nous a
réfuté notre premier truc lequel bah je
veux dire quand on a fait rocher deux
rois G3 F4 enfin on a fait que des trucs
normaux et puis tout d'un coup en fait
je commence à faire quelque chose
mais c'est le
la difficulté quoi tu t'attends à ce que
ne bouge pas et puis merde d'un coup de
tête
que penser de Becca RBK c'est un
problème enfin ce serait bien s'il y
avait pas un coup magique c'est la prise
en passant
je suis échange mais c'est pas la prise
en passant ce serait un bon coup
ton 4
jouer
voilà ce qui est dégueulasse c'est que
les meilleurs coups de l'ordi c'est de
tourbé 8 et tour à 8 en fait tu as pas
d'autres coups
et en fait
non
je t'annonce que la partie elle dure 5
quoi à partir d'ici
là on fait rien on fait ça j'imagine
bouffe ça en fait je me dis que sur ça
il y a peut-être qu'il y avait H4 qui
tue ça
elle a encore tu te prends le coup
interdit dans la tranche
en fait il y avait pas la prise en
passant ça tient peut-être
changer les règles du coup mais ça a
l'air un peu chiant cette idée est-ce
que après ça tue complètement bah ça a
l'air
avec les deux qui attaquent
mettre pression là-dessus les pions qui
peuvent se sacrifier ouvrir la colonne
et
là tu rentres sur les 15
en fait c'est juste fini
il y a combien de quoi jouer là il y a 5
coups avant la c'est terminé avant le
40e mais pour moi c'est terminé ce plan
là il fait trop mal
ouais
[Musique]
et d'essayer de toucher cette case là
en cas de F6 quoi
ouais après bon si on met le rang 2 et
peut-être des trucs c'est ça
non mais
bon ça a l'air capable mais de toute
façon c'est ta seule chance là
le truc c'est qu'en fait ça ça donne
l'impression de gagner
ok
donc tu dis que ta dame prend attends
j'ai 4 3 et 8
et G5 seul coup pour gagner parce que
sur kg ok bon c'est dur pour tout le
monde du coup ça c'est dur pour tout le
monde
ok joli coup quelque mais menace maths
et tu
bref
mais bon il va pas le faire il va pas
faire tourner vite
sur la même
et
est-ce qu'il y a que 5 kg
mais tout marche tout d'un coup
c'était le dernier clou dans le cercueil
bon j'ai envie de dire que pour
l'instant une constante c'est qui
l'un et l'autre il défendent pas très
bien quand ils sont pas bien ah ils
défendent relativement mal
alors je dis pas que c'est facile mais
n'est pas perdu facilement
et Ding à partir du moment où il s'est
pris j'ai pris un fils et mal défendu et
là bon depuis que je suis arrivé ça fait
pas si longtemps mais
ça glisse assez vite en fait surtout que
là il a glissé à part une position
difficile mais égale une nouvelle fois
objectivement tenable ouais ouais dur
mais je veux dire ok je m'attendais pas
à ça quoi
je veux dire je pensais que
normalement à ce niveau-là ils sont sont
d'excellents défenseurs justement non je
veux dire peut-être pas qu'il trouve
sous les coups de CC mais que ils
doivent perdre une longue finale chiante
et je sais pas mais là c'est
bon si j'ai cinq passes ça fait très
très mal et tu vois c'est pour ça qu'un
Nakamura
[Musique]
à terminer Naka
et c'est vrai que là il y a pas beaucoup
de barbe jusqu'à maintenant dans ce
match
ça manque de barbe
ouais enfin bon
enfin il vient de trouver vite quand
même enfin bon il a trouvé enfin
il passe son tour quoi méthode Batman
bon on va voir mais bon j'ai 5
j'ai 5 salaires de faire peur quoi
je sais pas si c'est le meilleur
objectif mais
donc là on a quantième coup on est au
36e avant le contrôle il a 10 minutes
Ding non il va pas tomber mais puis bon
moyen
un autre module pas très fort ici il dit
Roger 2 se place il prend son temps il
va peut-être faire toi F4 F6 après et
c'est un plan descend mais on aimait
bien G5 je sais pas si une défense en
fait
mais même ça permet à cause de caillou 5
et non parce qu'il faisait
et si on fait GH car le Saint Clair
[Musique]
pardon et donc
j'ai cinq dames d'essai puis on prend un
pion prend
F6 F6 c'est intéressant
du coup c'est sur le coup et
bon ça a l'air gagnant mais peut-être ça
c'est le faux amis parce que là alors
dit que 0,8 donc il y a eu des deux
c'est le coup hyper logique pour pouvoir
avoir cavalier 4 et défendre B4 mais ça
c'est bon
pourquoi pas mais je veux dire c'est
introuvable ça donne vraiment envie que
les blancs mais alors après j'ai vu que
dans le chat il disait que c'était
rangés deux genre sur le coup qui gagne
alors je sais pas ce qu'ils appellent
gagner qui donne un gros avantage quoi
sur moi donc
c'est pas si simple enfin tu viens de
faire il y a deux coups quand même
et donc du coup Dame des 7
j'imagine genre
c'est de nouveau le la connerie du
clouage de tout à l'heure ouais je crois
qu'il est ici ce que
je veux dire c'est peut-être celle-là
qui voulait pas avoir tout à l'heure
c'est que maintenant là la différence
avec l'orange G2 c'est que Adam français
mais c'est pas encore ce qu'on peut
appeler gagnant-gagnant
donc ouais c'est ça la ligne clé
après vous qui les coups avec les noirs
[Musique]
donc c'est pas le meilleur coup mais ça
c'est trop logique quoi quand
c'est clairement clairement son
attention
pas étonnant vu les positions qu'on a vu
mais je pense dans le 17 c'est le seul
coup qui est piagère je crois que tout
le reste mais c'est écrasé il a fait non
ou c'est toi
et donc un geste c'était quoi déjà ça
c'est
il y a pas F6 à cause de
puis on prend les H6
j'ai 5 pour essayer de fermer et FG
mais bon bref c'est clair il est facile
je l'avais il a joué
donc et
je crois que c'est juste fait défoncer
en fait
ouais mais c'est trop mais il a
relativement mal défendu
je sais pas c'est le même genre d'idée
tu voulais d'achetera les machins
après je sais pas peut-être là il a une
idée de défense clairement mais six mais
bon qui est étranger 5 menace 7
parce que sinon
[Musique]
même pas besoin peut-être de le faire
enfin
c'est la seule option 8 minutes
parce que là tu contrôle toutes les
cases donc
c'est trop facile il avance
[Musique]
que j'ai pas vu quoi il est très
confiant
mais
ouais bah écoute
bon le match ne cesse de me surprendre
dans ces scénario quoi
mais ouais c'est peut-être juste pas le
type de position pour Ding mais
juste il va de guetter de cœur là pour
le coup mais il va de gagner tout le
temps
il joue cette ligne il joue cette ligne
ouais mais c'est le temps on était
confiant pour Ding avant le jour de
repos autant là
bah là on retombe comme comme après les
deux premiers jours en gros
mais peut-être même encore pire parce
que là il semble avoir lieu un gros
problème avec les Noirs ah bah E4 le 4
pour l'instant c'est pas solutionné déjà
on a un c'était dur
mais pour ado gagner en journée
et là il fait une autre idée mais du
coup il doit en avoir pas mal en stock
et si je dors partout peut-être 5
je sais pas
des fois alors c'est moins son
répertoire main mais
[Musique]
je sais pas ce qui peut en stock mais si
c'est la souffrance à chaque fois c'est
pas possible quoi
il doit vraiment espérer que des quatre
reviennent sur l'échiquier quoi
[Musique]
l'ordinateur quand il y a plus rien à
faire il pète un câble parce que là il
propose ça bon enfin c'est
le seul coup c'est parce que tu fais
Damas 8 là bon ok bon bravo mais ça va
quand même pas aller quoi mais oui bravo
parce que ça c'est pas mal quoi
mais c'est pour ça que leur dit fait ce
genre de chose mais ça va pas être joué
dans la partie parce que tu vois que la
finale est complètement foutue
les profs bah pourquoi pas mais je crois
que c'est pas son style juste mais
peut-être à un moment tant pis
bon après
et c'est vraiment une ouverture de
championnat du monde mais le problème
c'est que niveau il connaît un peu quand
même quoi il doit avoir deux trois idées
aussi
non je sais pas enfin après peut-être il
peut faire 4,5 et puis tenir aussi mais
là les deux parties elles ont été dur
et c'est pas bon signe c'est à dire que
tu sens que mais il peut avec son
marteau il va taper et taper et taper
là-dessus quoi du coup faut quand même
un plan B peut être surtout que lui avec
les Blancs pour le moment il a trouvé
quelque chose mais c'était plus une idée
d'une partie et là il semble que nepo il
a trouvé un point faible
long terme quoi
bonding avec les Blancs il fait jouer
mais c'est pas des idées de
il va pas répéter mais il doit avoir
plein de petites idées comme ça
et pourquoi pas mais du coup ça a l'air
moins violent c'est-à-dire que va pas
toutes les perdre par contre là sur E4
pour l'instant on se dit qu'il peut
faire 100% quoi
une fois gagné une fois nul mais ça
suffit pour gagner le match donc il faut
réparer quoi clairement en tout cas il y
a un énorme problème
est-ce que c'est possible qu'il
abandonne non ouais c'est possible qu'il
joue F6 qui avait les H4 et abandon
il va pas abandonner l'autre jour il
avait un peu lutté
mais mais ça va pas changer la donne
grosse partie de Yann
on peut se laisser tomber autant aussi
il s'agit déjà vu des joueurs faire ça
pas abandonné mais c'est tombé quoi
tu trouves pas de coûte
tétanisé
le pion c'était le meilleur mais bon ok
mais même le dame c'est vite dame ou là
encore Auger encore dame d'essai il y a
eu des opportunités de faire des trucs
ça allait peut-être finir par perdre
mais
pas comme ça quoi en quelques coups
voilà ça a perdu on a rien de temps en
un claquement de doigts
mais les beaux dès qu'il était bien
c'est évident il faut éviter bien le
taureau 2 le G4 le taureau 4
G5
ouais non il a été extraordinaire
la partie qui pourrait bientôt se
terminer et on n'a pas de longues dans
ce match championnat du monde jusqu'à
maintenant c'est bizarre très étrange le
plus long que c'est la première en fait
5 heures et après
[Musique]
depuis c'est
ça gagne ou ça perd ouais mais c'est pas
je pense c'est parce que les cadences
sont trop courtes
donc on va bientôt avoir le coup là ne
partez pas
allez le retour du tweet pour annoncer
la victoire allez le retour du tweet
allez on envoie
mais genre tu crois que dans 10 minutes
c'est fini
sur quoi bah peu importe quoi
par exemple
est-ce que tu as mis le la sponso
aujourd'hui ouais bien sûr tu sers
attends
bon
il joue un coup de tour à 8
ouais alors il veut faire échec et dans
ma vie tu vas changer les dames
ça va peut-être pas fait en 10 minutes
parce qu'il va avoir une finale pourrie
à jouer du coup
mais je crois qu'il va pas se faire
échanger les dames il va pas il va pas
se remettre
le tweet tu peux tu fais comme tu veux
de toute façon je mets le tout
je prends des risques quand même
prends d'énormes à cause de toi
j'ai rien dit
vous l'avez vu il voulait en premier sur
Twitter
ça y est c'est Twitter
numéro 1 sur l'info ici comme toujours
important d'informer en premier les gens
et oui ça c'est sûr que c'est pas vrai
diri là il a pas annoncé encore on va
toujours me parler de diri ici
on dirait lui il a pas annoncé la
victoire
non mais ça peut un peu durer mais bon
normalement la vitesse
bon les autres vont le dire à 16h quoi
bon c'est 1h45 que ça a été dit ici
on me dit risquer ce tweet on va voir
à mon avis Gotham est déjà en train de
tourner sa vidéo
possible que tu fais un montage juste
pour finir quoi la fin de la partie
c'est ce qu'on aurait fait en réalité là
si bon on n'a jamais fait ça mais bon
je suis la fille et puis tu remontes
après tu fais partie 2
les gars
revenue
en fait en face du coup on a pas d'un
problème cette main et on a cette finale
là
bon qui font regagner mais qui qui est
cool quoi
parce que le pion h il est vraiment fort
quoi le royaume bois en plus il sera en
H8 bon ils sont dans un réseau de maths
mais
il est en train mais là
bon ok il faut que vous voyez tout ça
mais
bon étonnant s'il a pas quoi
on espère quand même mais bon ça
pourrait mettre à malmon tweet
non le problème c'est que la ligne est
forcé quoi
donc tu peux pas te tromper tu calcules
et
tu es à la ligne quoi
pourquoi pas on peut regarder mais en
deux tu vas te prendre dame cette échec
ou d'un 8 j'en sais rien des deux
et
bon j'en sais rien peut-être que ça
allait aussi mais bon déjà tu es pas
encore maths pareil et tu as passé le
40e mais bon là tu vois tu passes une
petite demi-heure à réfléchir
non mais je préfère l'autre
on peut rien faire peut-être mais oui je
préfère l'autre aussi parce que l'autre
en fait elle est en ligne droite G2
bon toute façon tu dois échanger les
dames là c'est encore pire tu appuies
tes échecs on t'échange on fait F6 bon
bah tu es quasi obligé de prendre quoi
enfin échec tu défends ton pion et
chaque peu plus le défendre tu peux pas
aller vers la suite qui bloque tu te
reprends échec et tu juste tu vois ça en
fait là tu as de calculer mais tu tu
vois que tu es gagnant puis bon après tu
finis quoi donc c'est bon en pratique
c'est clair que c'est mieux de faire ça
que de se baser qu'un rond en deux quoi
plus qu'une 23 pour pour Ding mais bon
il reste plus que de quoi jouer derrière
ça ça va être des coups facile
complexe
il y a un clouage justement c'est ce
qu'on disait de on l'a dit souvent quoi
quand il y a une dame des seins qui est
c'est la difficulté
noir mais
ça changera quoi tu aurais pu passer tu
aurais pu
pas mal de trucs
et prends G5 jouets on va avoir tout à 8
tours G2
va être joué
quelle partie
en fait le problème c'est que je trouve
que je joue pas bien en même temps
il a fait une bonne partie
une bonne partie mais
c'est vrai qu'ils ont pas été mis en
difficulté ou dans leur retranchement
pour
pour conclure mais déjà avoir une bonne
position c'est normalement c'est pas
facile
je veux dire genre n'est pas contre
Carson il a juste jamais été mieux non
j'ai même pas en tête qu'il ait fait
défendre
la partie qui l'a perdu ah oui mais bon
c'était encore
ouais mais le problème c'est que l'anti
Marshall il se faisait chier tout le
temps
terrible on n'est pas encore non mais
dans un coup alors il va ça va il a une
19 pour faire un coup et il va le faire
ça
c'est vrai
bon le truc c'est que ça fait longtemps
qu'on habite au match de Carlson oui
juste hyper jamais en fait
[Musique]
donc bon voilà et contre un an d'une
fois aussi mais bon donc en fait il a
perdu deux parties en 5 matchs
[Musique]
sinon non ça arrive en fait
bon là c'est beaucoup en fait après
cinq parties quoi
[Musique]
décisives c'est quand même rarissime
bon ok j'aurais pas fait ça mais ouais
en fait ça tu vas voir
bon de toute façon faire d'un musette et
puis toujours ton 40e et tu te
sens
gagner un tempo
bon ton avis
oh que oui mon Fab
30 secondes pour Ding il peut se laisser
tomber aussi et moi j'ai déjà vu ça
[Musique]
il peut se laisser tomber
mais je pense qu'il va jouer ouais là il
a une tête de quelqu'un qui va jouer
il a l'air dégoûté
tu sais pas tu cliques et tu te barres
à sa place
[Musique]
mais du coup tu as une heure pour faire
le prochain cours donc trouver une
défense miracle bon il faut qu'il y en a
pas donc voilà mais
il va chialer ouais
faire un tour au toilette boire un verre
marcher un peu
mais ouais la position va pas du tout
ça veut dire quoi reprendre une heure
bah en fait c'est la cadence pour jouer
les 40 premiers coups ils ont deux
heures donc là les 43 coups ont été
faits et après ils ont encore une heure
pour arriver au 60e mais ils ont encore
un quart d'heure après donc c'est ça
reprendre une heure ou alors je sais pas
si c'est le bon mot reprend mais
c'est que tu vois ça pendule la pendule
de l'un et l'autre ont été recrédité
d'une heure quoi
il a fait qu'il y avait les quatre
ok donc pas de F3
et H6
mais possible que Ding reviennent pas
avant 5 5 10 minutes là et surtout
Rachel tu as toujours le damas 8
ah non oui tarif pardon 8 et 8
respectez les joueurs ouais bon enfin
pas l'impression qu'on ne les respecte
pas
malheureusement
malheureusement la partie perdue bon si
tu veux on peut faire une petite pause
a été passé la fable complètement il a
passé le Rubicon il a pas l'air bien
Ding ouais de toute façon il va falloir
un petit moment on fait une petite pause
et on attend le retour de Ding et on
revient
à tout de suite
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs on a eu un coup
mais un coup qui change pas grand chose
d'un peu vite
un coup de
reculer
je pense qu'il veut
F6 pion prend H6 tours
ça doit être son idée
je suppose
mais en fait justement
bon je me dis ouais c'est pas con parce
que justement on veut faire F6 et
et s'il fait tout rachat
c'est juste pour simplifier les choses
je crois que même maintenant la colonne
ça permet de ne pas avoir besoin d'y
réfléchis
quoi oui je pense que même si tu fais
juste dames
ouais non bref du coup F3 ça crée quand
même cette menace et tu commences par F6
tu comprends et F3 peut-être alors là
OK
[Musique]
mais
oui du coup F3 dans ma vie OK
final je comprends pas pourquoi
peut-être temps
en fait mais
bon un moment il va juste l'accepter
cette finale et la finir mais bon moi il
se laisse pas mater
bah il fait il est le résistant le plus
longtemps possible non c'est bien de
faire ça par contre parce que tu
fatigues aussi ton adversaire quelque
part et sur bref on demande ce qui se
passe sur F6 bah ca va les prendre
écoute
on arrive au moment de la partie où
c'est un peu enfin il y a plus grand
chose à dire en réalité on est un peu on
est un peu bloqué parce que ça fait 30
minutes que la position est décidé
maintenant mais faut juste finir le
boulot alors c'est pas toujours le plus
simple là bon on pense quand même c'est
assez large pour nettoyer mais
ouais faut pas faut pas craquer quoi
mais
3 il y a FC ça probablement d'autres
coups qui gagnent d'ailleurs ouais froid
menaçage 6 aussi puis on prend ton G8 la
même chose mais oui en fait je le trouve
pas du tout tremblant en dépose pour ça
qu'en fait je me fais pas trop de soucis
pour lui on va dire facile
il a l'air facile
il est très facile même
alors que 60% des des personnes
pensaient qu'il allait pas la tenir
indigne quand j'ai posé la question il y
a une heure et demie de ça
donc le chat avait raison
les peaux lui a roulé dessus voilà il
s'est mis en boule et il roule quoi
tu vas rouler dessus au premier degré
même sur H6 gagne je suis moins sûr
parce que si on prend
ok alors gagnant mais après tu auras 4
non mais ça aussi ça l'a mais bon c'est
quoi ton con tu vois comment dire c'est
peut-être même ça ça gagne mais c'est
moins bien quoi enfin je sais pas si
c'est le plus fort mais c'est le coup
jouera d'abord parce que en fait on
prépare l'attaque et toujours on attaque
on tue quoi ça a rien de rentrer dans le
truc il faut faire repérer dans un
deuxième temps alors des fois il faut
faire parce qu'on peut pas améliorer
plus mais là pour qu'on joue avec un
Kevin et Chloé en fait
je pense que c'est vraiment la défaite
de trop bon en fait c'est tellement le
fond du trou les deux premières rondes
qui en fait il a pas déprimé il a
survenir qu'il y a pas de raison que là
il soit plus déprimé de celle-là par
contre le mauvais signe c'est qu'il
galère contre quatre
ça c'est très très mauvais signe après
match terminé non
on a vu que
que ça pouvait revenir
il a déjà pris une fois après il a plus
de problèmes pour le moment avec les
noirs que
[Musique]
Yann
c'est aussi une réalité
on est en attente du coup là tout gagne
en fait c'est un peu un peu bizarre
après ils ont raison de prendre leur
temps
il y a plus de victoire que de nul pour
le moment ouais donc tant qu'il y aura
qu'un point d'écart tu sais que ça peut
toujours revenir au classement surtout
que Ding va doubler les blancs je pense
j'en suis même sûr en fait quand ils
font leur jour de repos là il double
ouais
on va voir lundi mercredi
mais du coup il va avoir et après avoir
blanc mardi et blanc
du coup c'est le moment d'égaliser
c'est bizarre
cette fois-ci ils ont changé
comment on peut voir
non mais si il va doubler
il lui donne mardi
il est blanc il aura eu 4 blancs trois
noirs il double en trois noirs donc ça
peut pas femme
oh mais c'est pas possible
[Musique]
mais non mais c'est mathématique
j'en sais rien
en fait il va avoir trois quatre et
après c'est une époque qui refait avec
les Blancs non mais bon oui mais là on
en est où là c'est synchrone c'est 3,2
demain sera 3 3
et nepo 5 3 c'est pas possible ça fera
un peu trop
mais je sais pas comment il double rien
du tout c'est aussi possible qu'il
double pas mais si double setting mais
je crois qu'il aime bien doubler mais
truc que je comprends pas c'est que
d'habitude il double pour redonner dans
l'autre sens les jours ça pour jouer
deux fois et du coup ça digne qui est
les blancs en premier et une épaule et
noir à chaque fois faire un genre de
miroir
en attendant bon logique bonjour des
Fidji ben écoute j'espère que c'est cool
les Fidji
ça va être sympa les filles ça doit être
bien et
ça joue pas mal à chaque fois
il leur manque un peu de
mais ça dépend dans quel rugby rugby à 7
ils sont champions olympiques pas grand
chose ça dépend de quel type de rugby on
parle mais
mais à 15 ouais les avant ils manquent
un peu il manque quoi il manque pas
grand chose il se faut aussi piller par
les la Nouvelle-Zélande
beaucoup de joueurs donc c'est sûr que
si à chaque fois que tu as un mec qui
est vraiment très bon en fait il pleut
il se fait naturaliser bon au bout d'un
moment c'est comme si au foot on
travaille
un peu tout le monde tu restes fort mais
un peu moins ouais tu commences à suer
quoi
qui sont pas mal
qui sont les plus forts
je sais pas ce que ça va valoir les gens
supérieures je veux dire là pour la
Ligue 2 il est il est excellent Enfin
plus qu'excellent quoi il marche sur le
championnat
et globalement ce que je pense c'est que
juger mes doutes sur ses qualités
défensives genre quand on a commencé on
joue en 4K c'était pas ouf mais depuis
qu'il est dans son couloir et qu'on
rejoint 300 trop
ouais il est bon après voilà je sais pas
si tu mets en Ligue 1 si ça serait
pareil mais
là rien à dire très bonne pioche quoi
bref voilà c'était le moment foot
ouais mais pour Ding c'est dur alors
trois chances que c'est un coup pour
Ding bah on l'a vu hein
on a de prendre un geste et de faire
kayf6 donc du coup
ça va pas
c'est la fameuse variante
juste pas possible en fait
donc ouais ça peut finir assez vite en
fait
ça va abandonner Fab
FC
il est en train de boire le calice
jusqu'à la lit parce qu'elle a dit il
doit pas être bien
pas une grande partie après elle était
assez logique de part et d'autre mais
ouais le moment clé là les dame aussi
les dames des stats les machins là ici
c'est un peu la mécanique c'est grippé à
ce moment là
et après
on va le voir abandonner mes amis
et le tweet qui était juste une nouvelle
fois premier sur l'actu on l'a déjà mis
à quelle heure cette fois-ci
je prends des risques mais il paye pour
le moment il paye très très fort
bah j'essaye de gagner des abos sur
Twitter 36 minutes j'ai que 100 si likes
pour le résultat c'est incroyable
ouais c'est bizarre parce que tu as des
infos quand même qui sortent avant tout
le monde
j'en profite pour parler de la
proceastique aussi fable 12 mai à 18h on
sera ensemble à Paris pour suivre le
match vous pouvez trouver le lien pour
la billetterie point d'exclamation watch
party dans le dans le chat ici aussi ici
aussi j'ai rajouté un événement tchaikom
non non collaboration
du coup ouais ce sera le 12 mai 18h le
match ce sera l'équipe de Blitz donc
notre team avec avec Richard Baki Katia
Maël contre contre les Indiens avec
visite probablement Praga un indien
qu'on connaît pas trop et vaille c'est
le plaisir de voir Charlie quand même
c'est la sœur de la salle
ça me met très très bien donc ce sera à
dispote juste à côté du Louvre si vous
voulez des places il faut se dépêcher il
n'en reste plus que 47 je crois ce qui
est pas beaucoup parce qu'on va bientôt
faire le best of sur Youtube où on en
reparlera donc si vous voulez suivre le
match en notre compagnie
ce sera ce sera là-bas les dégoût de
lignes
on nous propose mais puis on prend puis
on prend enfin non mais oui ça peut pas
tenir je veux dire c'est juste repousser
les chiens mais de ne pas grand chose
d'ailleurs mais c'est quand tu fais ça
tu sais que tu as perdu quoi
toujours pas de date de la backup bah si
c'est le 17 juin
je sais pas alors je me suis trompé
à 100% donc alors on n'est pas sûr quoi
enfin
en fait si ce sera le 17 mais si ça
si pour une raison X ou Y ça avait pas
lieu
je suis ah c'est terrible ce qu'il fait
digne fabricade
c'est aussi bien que la victoire de nepo
ah bah ouais mais bon j'ai pas assez de
like pour celui qui attend j'ai combien
de like j'en ai très peu c'est
incroyable
115 à peine quoi
c'est c'est quoi dire rien
c'est terrible
peut-être les gens ils s'en foutent du
résultat en fait ok oui mais bon vous
allez les résultats en avant-première
il veut juste pas abandonner en fait
ouais bon après pourquoi pas enfin
faut juste pas qu'il se rende malade à
jouer ça quoi
ici
ça marche
il a fait tour à deux OK
[Musique]
il a un petit piège problème c'est que
niveau va pas tomber dedans
donc il peut monter le roi ça a l'air
très bien
et surtout
tes problèmes et
pas un problème
si on peut appeler ça des problèmes oui
bon gros c'est le
non quelque chose
d'honneur ouais ouais après là ça dure
ça dure pour durer
non mais après pourquoi pas enfin je
veux dire oui non mais moi j'aurais
peut-être
[Musique]
j'espère que peut-être les blancs se
trompent
il y a vraiment peu de chance mais
peut-être une sur 1000 et je suis même
pas sûr mais peut-être
le baron fou d'honneur
la pro châssis c'est quand le quart de
finale c'est le 12 mai donc amusé point
d'exclamation watch Party et tu peux il
y a une billetterie pour venir suivre le
match en direct
il y aura pas les joueurs sur place mais
ça va être assez sympa il y aura des il
y aura un coffre de supporters j'espère
qu'il y aura des tambours bon on va
essayer de faire un truc un peu sympa
c'est une sorte de grande fan zone quoi
ouais c'est un genre de fan zone ce sera
la première fois dans l'histoire des
échecs que ce sera fait
en fait c'était un peu ce qu'on a fait
Lisbonne mais en
organisé exprès et ouais alors c'est
complètement différent non non mais oui
beaucoup mieux genre c'est un peu
l'esprit exactement
c'est une femme zone exactement
malheureusement je crois que je serai
pas là
je crois que c'était ça
ouais je crois que tu m'as dit ça
ce sera sympa ouais à Paris 18 heures
le vendredi donc 12 mai et après si on
gagne on refera normalement direct le
samedi parce que la demi-finale sera le
samedi et le dimanche
à s’enchaîne ça enchaîne maintenant ça
devait être en réel oui mais c'est ça on
avait beaucoup plus de chance de gagner
en réel ouais c'est dommage là on était
bien
là on aurait été très très bien Fab
ok donc ouais donc ça peut être 12 13 14
au final
[Musique]
ça nous met très très bien
ça nous mettrait très très bien
donc on va espérer gagner
ouais bon alors pas évident mais
franchement je trouve qu'on a une belle
équipe
d'après bon les autres signes mais il y
a que des belles équipes à ce niveau de
la compétition mais bon déjà on a
éliminé l'équipe de Carlsen c'est déjà
sympa
qui avait fait faux bon la dernière
minute mais ça a rien changé vu le match
et vu le score il a fait trois et demi
je pense pas qu'il aurait battu Maxime
avec les pièces noires Maxime l'aurait
fermé vu le scénario du match
donc ça aurait pas fait mieux guéri donc
ça ça n'a pas non tu peux pas en vouloir
un mec qui fait trop de missions
même pas changé la physionomie du match
j'aurais gagné les deux premières pareil
il aurait fait nul la troisième pareil
et il aurait peut-être même pas gagné la
quatrième quoi enfin
de la partie ben on le fera je pense
après sur Youtube on a des gens on a
déjà largement parlé
de cette partie
belle partie
franchement pas trop mal ouais
non mais j'aime bien comme on n'est pas
joué voilà ça me parle mais le petit
regret c'est que ouais il a pas été
poussé en se retranchement à chercher
des mégas subtilités
enfin après lui il va être très content
et en soit c'est une jolie partie qu'on
pourra revoir dans des livres justement
stratégie l'échange du front de le
cavalier parce que la structure est
fixée il est trop surcasse blanche etc
etc donc je vais aller bien construite
mais ouais Ding aurait pu mieux défendre
quoi
il aurait même dû mieux défendre alors
après c'est toujours dur eux bon ils ont
pas les modules ça joue sur des petits
détails ou quoi mais il y a quand même
un ensemble de petites décisions qui à
la fin il faut une grosse grosse
différence
complètement
et le match concernant c'est le 12 mai
je le répète ça ce serait c'est quand
même un bel événement qu'on organise
chetcom cette pro chess League Fab on
espère que ça prenne et qu'on réussisse
vraiment dans les années à venir à voir
quelque chose de d'encore plus gros
entre guillemets bah je trouve juste
dommagement qui est pas un événement
réel pour finir
parce que là bon ça aurait été parfait
ou au moins avoir pas forcément dans le
même lieu mais au moins que tout le
monde soit réel
différent quoi en gros exactement
on sera celui de Paris mais ça aurait
été bien et que chacun ait son e-spot
quoi avec les joueurs etc évidemment ça
demande beaucoup plus de budget
globalement dans la ligue mais bon
franchement je trouve qu'il y a déjà des
beaux buts qui pourraient se permettre
de faire ça mais bon
peut-être un peu moins d'argent dans les
prices poules un peu plus dans le dans
la on va appeler ça la sécurité
du coup on verra si
c'est les spécialistes sont aussi
spécialistes dans les dans le public
quoi
tu es encore plus spécialiste chez toi
parfois mais on sait pas on peut pas
savoir ah oui mais on sait pas
du coup ça va permettre de savoir quoi
pour jouer tranquillement Fab
[Musique]
c'est moi qui crée la première compète
online en présence si elle ouais
c'est moi qui ai fait ça aussi ouais
j'ai créé deux trois trucs
j'ai créé deux trois trucs pas mal
événement aussi et c'est vrai que là
est-ce que tu es aussi spécialiste on
sait pas d'ailleurs on a bien vu même
des joueurs comme Seb qui performent pas
trop sur Internet normalement bah là on
a vu que il jouait vraiment bien plus
spécialiste en public
non mais après
mais on a vu qu'en fait la 2D 3D ça
change pas grand chose quand tu vois la
finale genre bah qui lui est vraiment
habitué à la 3D à la 2D maintenant
l'habitude mais tu vois sur une backup
que
ça change peut-être le niveau mais à la
marge
l'épaisseur du trait moins que ce qu'on
aurait pu penser parce que parfois tu
dis ça te change de changer 200 300
points
mais bon petit à petit on va tous
s'habituer je vais en donner
plus qu'il y a quelques années quoi
de leur dire et tout il finit tu
t'habitues
en tout cas ça réfléchit encore côté
Yann
bon écoute j'aime bien l'attitude
belle attitude non mais il a mûri par
rapport à ses plus jeunes années où il
arrive vraiment voulu se tenir tempo
gagner comme ça mais là au moins il veut
être sûr et qu'il va calculer une ligne
qui finit la partie quoi et il a bien
raison sans laisser de contre chance
il va faire percer mon twitter et mon
truc qui perce pas
il pourrait percer oui il veut vendre
des places pour la Watch party ou faire
des nouveaux abonnés pour la chaîne
Youtube de chascom
peut vouloir faire beaucoup de choses il
fait froid donc c'est pareil que Roy F4
bon je suis pas sûr que Ding va beaucoup
continuer
pour prendre B2
jouer 5mg
[Musique]
beaucoup de choses sont fortes
on va bientôt finir
ça devrait
s'arrêter net
ça fait un moment que c'est terminé
qui tente encore de trouver quelque
chose mais il y a rien à trouver
dans cette position il va falloir
accepter la défaite
ment
bon oui en fait son dernier espoir
c'était ce que vous avez dit ici c'est
que si les blancs veulent gagner comme
il le fera en force avec cavalier là
pousse le pion mais la tour pour enlever
le roi ben là en fait il te reprends
pion
voilà c'était ça le dernier espoir pour
aller sacrifier parce que ce pion est
trop fort faut pas le laisser en vie
c'était pas un piège très dur et faire
ce final mais oui ça se voit vite quoi
en fait et bah du coup il est pas tombé
dedans et bon voilà
complexe
pour
montre une photo sur le sur le Twitter
de chasse.com
il a pas l'air bien
six heures de Parme sur la photo
dure dur dur dur dur dur
est-ce que la nuit est possible moi je
donne quoi je donne une chance sur un
million pour la nul là je vois même pas
je sais même pas c'était pas optimiste
tu peux aller avec ton partiel
franchement tu vas pas rater grand chose
non non là c'est plus possible c'est pas
possible
c'est de tout en F2 ça sauve pas le
problème c'est que pareil tu as
peut-être repousser les chances mais le
roi va monter en F5 G6 ou E6 et depuis
un F a décidé quoi
en fait on va voir sacrifier la tour à
la qualité contre les deux pions F bon
là ça serait nul les autres cas de
figure non quoi
c'est noir serait mieux
bon mieux je suis pas sûr mais oui
normalement il défendons
mais c'est un gros ci quoi c'est
disparaître la meilleure pièce à pire
ouais
le bide qui va pas sauver une peau
aujourd'hui
et finalement la partie qui dure
trois heures là on dépasse les 4 heures
de jeu
artificiellement c'est dur
er une demi-heure du coup vu qu'il a 32
minutes mais
en fait on sait déjà depuis une heure
quand même le résultat quoi
ouais des fois en fait ça dure il y a
une finale ou tu es un peu mieux ou tu
es bien mieux mais c'est pas facile à
gagner ça met du barbone et on sait pas
trop quoi
là
est-ce que il y a un intérêt côté dix
Milly Rennes à continuer ici Fab
j'espère un miracle
à t'espères pas ton truc c'est trop
simple mais qu'en fait il y a un miracle
dans la position genre un truc d'étude
ou bon bah il y a pas on sait mais lui
bon
de toute façon
qui se chauffe pour faire les annonces
je fais des annonces quoi
il est mal
ouais difficile il y a plus plus grand
chose à dire on a fait le tour de la
position on a fait le tour des enjeux
l'ordinateur affiche ma 125 coups enfin
c'est mécanique mais bon du coup on peut
parler des euh de demain donc Dingler
les blancs on va voir comment il réagit
[Musique]
bon pour moi il faut qu'il continue sa
stratégie
mais avec les Blancs il fait jouer et
puis et puis on verra pourquoi est-ce
qu'on récupère une heure de temps alors
au 40e coup en fait tu as deux heures
pour les 40 premiers coups et au 40e
coup c'est la règle du jeu tu récupères
une heure de plus pour pouvoir bien
réfléchir pour avoir bien le temps quoi
après ça dépend des cadences c'est une
cadence parmi tant d'autres mais en fait
c'est la cadence on va dire classique
historique et historique quand on était
petit il y avait pas les pendules avec
les 30 secondes ou quoi mais on jouait
des parties très longues de 8h quoi avec
on avait déjà le 40 coups deux heures
on avait une heure encore pour le 60e et
encore une heure pour finir donc ça
pouvait dur à 8 heures ils ont un petit
peu raccourci mais là ça reste quand
même très long mais
mais bon après je sais pas pourquoi
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
le minimum pour qu'on puisse appeler des
parties longues enfin que ça compte pour
le classement et l'eau et que ce soit
des parties classiques c'est 1h30 + 30
secondes pour toute la partie mais il va
peut-être un peu réformer ça j'ai
entendu qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
aiment la cadence 45 minutes plus 45
secondes ou un truc comme ça
pourquoi pas en fait
mais déjà le 1h30 il est pas mal je veux
dire ça peut être plus court mais déjà
1h30 + 30 secondes tu as le temps de
faire une bonne partie 60 minutes plus
30 secondes en France ouais mais alors
c'est moins de 2200 ou 2004 ou je sais
pas quoi mais c'est pour les plots mais
moi j'ai pas le droit de jouer ça
[Musique]
va vite ouais bon ça va vite ça dure
quand même 2h30 donc bon oui non mais
tout va vite mais en fait au moins ça
permet de jouer plusieurs parties dans
la journée etc enfin toutes les gamins
sont leurs avantages ou leurs
inconvénients mais non ça du cash price
pour le gagnant alors il y a un million
deux pour le gagnant du match et 800000
pour le perdant donc 2 millions de prix
en tout un différentiel de 400.000 euros
entre la win et la et la loose c'est
peut-être pas ça
[Musique]
je suis gentil avec toi tu as perdu
limite on crache dessus
à la gueule quand même au passage
d'un million 9 et 100000 ouais c'est
plus plus logique voilà tu fais des
boîtes
tu perds tu dois choisir une boîte une
boîte avec 800000 tu as une boîte avec
400000 et tu as une boîte avec zéro quoi
et c'est comme au jeu à la cool
je te propose je te pose 300000
qu'est-ce que tu fais
pas bien tu as deux chansons
c'est vrai que c'est un choix je pense
que j'accepte moi je suis peut-être non
ici je pense mais j'aurais dégoûté de
moi oui parce qu'en fait c'est pas le
bon coup statistique
[Rires]
en fait j'avais lu que des fois c'est
intéressant statistiquement de
l'échanger ou quoi mais il y a une loi
statistique pour savoir si tu dois
échanger ou pas mais en fait moi j'ai
pas envie enfin c'est ma boîte je la
garde quoi
j'y crois dans ma boîte
statistique
faut échanger ouais parce qu'il y a de
base tu avais une chance sûrement
d'avoir le truc après que tu as plus
qu'une chance sur toi et un truc mais je
sais j'avais vu
[Musique]
après tu es un peu méfiant après il me
propose de changer ben ouais non mais en
fait surtout je serais dégoûté d'avoir
eu la boîte à 800000 et de l'avoir
balancer quoi
complexe
Ding se fait déboîter exactement
mais voilà ça réfléchit longtemps pour
une position où il y a ma force hein
franchement c'est c'est rare défendre un
peu ça va mais des référent aussi
longtemps c'est particulier
il faut qu'il faut qu'il se fasse
[Musique]
boîte head
ou plutôt des boîtes
ça peut tenir
quoi
un jeu de mots il y a un truc ou je sais
pas je sais pas
non mais en plus il se fatigue même pas
je veux dire
en fait je sais même pas ce qui calcule
il est plus là
[Musique]
qui a aucune chance peut-être
je pense que même s'il mettait un pion
H4 ouais il est quand même enfin ouais
non mais là
il faut un cavalier à 5 il est quand
même perdant je pense
même sur
mais bon il peut revenir en C6 te faire
échec en E5 sauter un F7 défendre des
maths peut-être
[Musique]
c'est terrible
enfin là j'aurais pas pensé quand on a
terminé la pause que ça dure encore plus
d'une demi-heure oui non
quand j'ai fait le twitch je pensais
qu'il restait plus de 10 minutes mais
genre entre 20 et 30 minutes je pensais
et là le tweet il a déjà plus d'une
heure
oui
moi
je suis vraiment le premier sur l'info
quoi
moi je n'en veux pas de faire
[Musique]
ce qu'il en veut mais
victoire de Yann n'est pas bien chez qui
reprend l'avantage dans ce match
Fab il passe
il repart il passe à trois points
ouais ok bah écoute
bravo bonne partie comme on disait juste
digne il y a peut-être pas défendu au
top mais ok c'est comme ça il va falloir
que son équipe travaille bien pour
réparer les noirs sur E4 parce que là ça
commence à être problématique
et sinon bon il peut égaliser demain
éventuellement je voulais enfin je suis
pas plus inquiet que ça
bon c'est pas fait non plus mais je
crois que ce sera dans son état normal
en fait il va jouer une partie et on
verra bien quoi exactement enfin donc on
sera de retour demain à 11h digne qui
aura les pièces blanches et ce qui va
réussir à se relever de cette défaite et
ce qui va couler est-ce que bon il va
rester à flot avec une nulle on verra
bien est-ce qu'il réussit à trouver un
nouveau coup une nouvelle préparation
pour mettre nepo à mal ça aussi c'est la
grande question parce qu'il semble que
nepo a pris un petit avantage là dessus
lui il a une cible claire maintenant
dans le match
c'est l'anti Marshall ou il semble
dominer dans le jeu d'ingly Rennes côté
Ding le le la préparation qui lui est
dans la deuxième partie c'était un peu
un one shot c'était pour une partie donc
il a pas encore lui de cible claire chez
son adversaire donc le match s'annonce
pas le python mais Yann qui reprend
un avantage clair dans dans cette
confrontation merci à tous d'avoir suivi
merci Fab pour le commentaire et on se
retrouve demain à 11h pour la suite du
tournoi et un petit peu plus tard
aujourd'hui pour l'analyse de la partie
on vous remercie on vous dit à très
bientôt Ciao